das wort hat die bundesministerin des
innern und für heimat
nancy faeser
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren heute vor einem monat
hat putin mit seinem furchtbaren
verbrecherischen angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine begonnen millionen von menschen
fliehen vor gewalt und zerstörung sie
suchen zuflucht auch in unserem land
viele bürgerinnen und bürger zeigen sich
solidarisch und helfen sehr aktiv ihnen
allen gebührt mein großer respekt und
dank
auch der staat beweist in der jetzigen
lage seine handlungsfähigkeit kommunen
länder und der bund leisten in dieser
herausfordernden situation einen grossen
humanitären kraftakt unsere haupt
augenmerk ist dabei die bestmöglichste
versorgung unterbringung und verteilung
der geflüchteten in deutschland und in
der gesamten eu jetzt geht es darum den
historischen schulterschluss den wir
durch die gemeinsame aufnahmen der eu
erreicht haben in praktisches handeln
umzusetzen
das hat meine oberste priorität
wir etablieren bus und zugverbindungen
um geflüchtete aus polen und deutschland
nach frankreich zu bringen und von dort
in andere eu-staaten mein dank gilt
ausdrücklich frankreich die einen harten
mit uns gemeinsam eingerichtet haben
nach bordeaux nach dijon und lyon
wir haben von anfang an gemeinsam mit
dem bundesverkehrsministerium eine
stabsstelle für die koordinierung der
verteilung der ankommenden eingerichtet
täglich sind in unserem auftrag
sonderzüge und busse unterwegs auch bei
der registrierung unterstützt mein haus
die länder sowohl personell als auch
materiell um den geflüchteten eine
zentrale vertrauenswürdige digitale
anlaufstelle in deutschland bereit zu
stellen haben wir kurzfristig das hilfs
portal germany for you crane entwickelt
um darüber hinaus die erste orientierung
in deutschland zu erleichtern öffnen wir
die integrations und sprachkurse für
schutzsuchende aus der ukraine
und ich will betonen was mir persönlich
besonders am herzen liegt und deswegen
haben wir den schutz dort auch sehr
verstärkt ist der schutz der
geflüchteten frauen die hier in
deutschland ankommen ihnen gilt unsere
gesamte aufmerksamkeit
auch die beschaffung von hilfsgütern und
medizinischem material für die ukraine
und angrenzende staaten haben für mich
eine hohe priorität
mein besonderer dank und ich denke unser
aller gilt den einsatzkräften des thg
der bundespolizei und des bamf dank
ihrer engagierten arbeit und des großen
engagements und das will ich hier noch
einmal betonen die ehrenamtlichen
helferinnen und helfer und der
hilfsorganisation kann man gar nicht
hoch genug einschätzen deswegen noch
einmal ein ausdrückliches dankeschön an
alle gerade die ehrenamtliche kräfte in
unserem land
der überfall russlands auf die ukraine
ist eine zäsur und wir müssen unsere
sicherheit auch im lichte neuer
realitäten sehen deswegen möchte ich
klar vorweg sagen das wird auch
zusätzliche finanzielle belastungen nach
sich ziehen die in diesem haushalt noch
nicht berücksichtigt sind jetzt
ausdrücklich sagen weil ich denke hier
insbesondere an weitere investitionen
die erforderlich sein werden jetzt in
dem zivilschutz den grenzschutz die
innere sicherheit und vor allen dingen
und das hat oberste priorität den
integrationsbereich aber auch die
deutsche cyber
sicherheitsarchitektur werden wir weiter
stärken wir haben alle schutzmaßnahmen
gegen russische attacken hochgefahren
kommen wir nun zum vorliegenden
haushaltsentwurf das bundesministerium
des innern und für heimat hat sich für
die nächsten
vier jahre hohe ziele gesetzt wir wollen
sicherheit im wandel gewährleisten und
bringen das voran was wir als
fortschritts koalition uns vorgenommen
haben wir wollen sicherheit für alle
gewährleisten unsere demokratie stärken
und entschieden gegen jede form von
extremismus vorgehen
wir wollen deutschland zu einem
vielfältigen einwanderungsland machen
menschen integrieren aber auch mit aller
härte straftäter und gefährden ihre
heimatländer zurück führen wir wollen
eine bürgernahe transparente und
digitale verwaltung schaffen krisen
meistern und auf katastrophen
vorbereitet sein und ich will den
zusammenhalt in unserer gesellschaft
fördern und mich für gleichwertige
lebensverhältnisse stark machen und beim
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhang kommt
vor allen dingen auch dem sport eine
große rolle zu
der vorliegende haushaltsentwurf schafft
dafür die basis wir stärken mit
zusätzlichen mitteln und neun stellen
die innere sicherheit in unserem land
der haushaltsentwurf sieht für den
einzelplan das bmi ein gesamtvolumen von
rund 15 milliarden euro vor das ist ein
plus von 1,6 milliarden euro im
vergleich zum ursprünglichen finanzplan
und das sind
1660 stellen mehr für sicherheit
integration und zusammenhalt
und ich kann den bürgerinnen und bürgern
versichern dieses geld ist gut
investiert
wir werden rechtsextremismus
linksextremismus und islamismus
frühzeitig und entschlossen bekämpfen
politische bildung prävention und
entschlossenes handeln unserer
sicherheitsbehörden
gehören aus meiner sicht eng zusammen
und das habe ich auch in mit dem
aktionsplan gegen rechtsextremismus
dargestellt auf der einen seite
präventive maßnahmen auf der anderen
seite die ganze härte des rechtsstaates
wir nehmen zusätzliche gelder in die
hand um unsere sicherheitsbehörden
besser auszustatten und auf dem stand
der technik zu halten
als zeichen der wertschätzung unserer
polizistinnen und polizisten wollen wir
die ruhegehalts fähigkeit der polizei zu
lage wieder einführen das bedeutet für
mich echte wertschätzung keine
sonntagsreden und ich finde das haben
die polizeibeamtinnen und beamten in
unserem land mehr als verdient
wir werden aber auch dass
bundespolizeigesetzes novellieren wir
investieren in den ausbau des netzes des
bundes und in die it-sicherheit wir
wollen integration von anfang an das ist
ein schlüssel für den zusammenhalt
unserer gesellschaft wir bauen die
integrationskurse aus und verbessern das
kursangebot wir setzen die förderung von
jüdischen einrichtungen
konsequent fort und bekämpfen
antisemitismus mit aller entschiedenheit
zu einem modernen staat gehört eine
bürokratiearme transparente und digitale
verwaltung das müssen bürgerinnen und
bürger in ihrem alltag aber auch spüren
deshalb sehen wir erhebliche mittel für
die digitalisierung von
verwaltungsdienstleistungen vor mit dem
haushaltsentwurf setzen wir außerdem
sehr wichtige akzente im bereich des
bevölkerungsschutzes und der
katastrophenhilfe wir müssen künftig
besser auf mögliche krisen katastrophen
und klimafolgen vorbereitet sein das
bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe wurde mit dem
konjunkturpaket des haushaltes 20 21 mit
zusätzlichen sachmitteln in höhe von
fast 100 millionen bereits erheblich
gestärkt zudem kam 50 stellen hinzu mit
dem jetzt vorgeschlagenen haushalt
satteln wird darauf nochmal auf das bbk
soll für 2022 insgesamt nochmals 112
stellen und 19 5 millionen mehr erhalten
das sind sogar 32 millionen euro mehr
als geplant und wenn ich ihnen das sagen
darf ja wohl angesichts der aktuellen
lage freue ich mich auf ihre
unterstützung in einem ergänzungs
haushalt da noch mal drauf zu satteln
meine damen und herren wir
bekennen uns zu unserer
schutzverantwortung wenn menschen vor
krieg und verfolgung fliehen es ist
richtig dass wir die ausgaben für
humanitäre aufnahmen erhöhen deshalb
unterstütze ich auch die beabsichtigte
stärkung des bundeshaushalts im
ergänzungs haushalt auch in dieser
hinsicht meine damen und herren wir
wollen die gesellschaftliche kraft des
sports stärken dazu setzen wir auf
integration und inklusion im sport aber
wir fördern natürlich auch den
spitzensport und haben deshalb auch dort
die mittel erhöht und die spitzensport
reform steht weiterhin an unter anderem
wollen wir die großereignisse wie die
nationalen spiele der special olympics
22 und die special olympics world games
unterstützen und wir wollen starb darauf
freuen wir uns alle die fußball-em 2024
in deutschland zu einem großen fest des
sportlers machen
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
wir haben uns viel vorgenommen und ich
möchte dass mit ihnen gemeinsam umsetzen
mein dank für die vertrauensvolle
zusammenarbeit gilt allen
berichterstattern berichterstatter im
haushaltsausschuss ich darf besonders
stabiler schäfer dr thorsten lieb und
natürlich martin gerster dabei erwähnen
herzlichen dank ich werbe für ihre
unterstützung die herausforderungen sind
sehr groß dieser krieg mit einer europa
zeigt äußere und innere sicherheit
gehören zusammen gerade jetzt müssen wir
sie stärken vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat die kollegin andrea
lindholz für die cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und hier im deutschen bundestag sind wir
mittlerweile beim einzelplan
s6 angekommen inneres und heimat also
der das ministerium von
bundesinnenminister rinser die hat sich
hier auch schon dazu geäußert hat unter
anderem ihre einige schwerpunkte hier
aufgezählt sie möchte die
sicherheitsbehörden besser ausstatten
wie cyber abwehr ausbauen deutschland zu
einem vielfältigen
einwanderungsland machen unter anderem
mit sport den sie stärken möchte aber
auch extremismus bekämpfen und in
politische bildung und prävention
investieren mittlerweile sind wir jetzt
schon in der aussprache
und da können wir jetzt auch gleich
reinhören andrea lindholz spricht gerade
die stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender der unionsfraktion
brauchen wir neben geld auch weitsicht
und wir brauchen auch die bereitschaft
führungsverantwortung zu sehen und zu
übernehmen und das liebe frau ministerin
vermisse ich an der einen oder anderen
stelle
in ihrem aktionsplan rechtsextremismus
da betreiben sie vor allem eines und das
ist augenwischerei denn vieles aus dem
plan hatten wir schon in der letzten
legislaturperiode auf den weg gebracht
ich nenne hier das förderprogramm
demokratie im netz oder auch den
lagebericht zu rechtsextremisten im
öffentlichen dienst um rechtsextreme
netzwerke auf effektiv aufdecken zu
können brauchen die sicherheitsbehörden
aber moderne befugnisse es reicht nicht
dass ich das festnetz abhören darf oder
sms-nachrichten wenn ein solcher zustand
erreicht es dann muss es mir auch
möglich sein messenger dienste mit
quellen tk und online-durchsuchungen
durchsuchen zu können und da ist es eben
nicht ausreichend wenn wir hier keine
modernen befugnisse haben
und bei der aufnahme der
kriegsflüchtlinge aus der ukraine
beharren sie
verglich verweigern sie hier die
übernahme der führungsverantwortung in
unserem land nach wie vor kommt täglich
bis zu 10.000 frauen und kinder nach
deutschland seit wochen warnen polizei
und helfer vor pädophilen und
menschenhändlern die dieses chaos
ausnutzen und trotzdem es gibt zwar in
der zwischenzeit endlich mehr präsenz
der bundespolizei an den bahnhöfen aber
es gibt immer noch keine schutzzone und
keine geordnete aufnahme und es geht
einfach nicht
es gibt auch bis heute trotz ja
ihrerseits immer wieder vorgenommene
ankündigungen keine systematischen
registrierung bei der einreise so wie es
die polen machen und wir wissen eben
nicht genau werden unser land kommt und
die verteilung in unserem land
funktioniert eben nicht reibungsfrei sie
muten hier den kommunen ganz massive
belastungen zu bei mir im wahlkreis ist
gestern ein bus mit flüchtlingen
angekommen die eigentlich nach
niedersachsen hätten fahren sollen die
waren zutiefst verunsichert sie waren
verängstigt und es war auch für die
helfer vor ort eine sehr schwierige
situation
vor drei tagen sind bei uns große
überhaupt nicht angekommen obwohl die
helferinnen und helfer stundenlang
gewartet haben um dann kurz vor
mitternacht zu erfahren dass die busse
gar nicht erst abgefahren sind ich
bringe das bewusst als beispiel das in
berlin nicht abgefahren es ist wichtig
dass wir dem ehrenamt danken arbeit
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrte frau ministerin damit
frustrieren wir das ehrenamt dieses
chaos müssen sie sofort abstellen wir
müssen wer kommt und die personen vor
ort müssen informiert sein
es braucht den nationalen krisenstabes
braucht auch den nationalen flüchtlings
gipfel und wenn wir schon nicht auf die
union hören damit verbesserungen
eintreten dann hören sie doch wenigstens
auf die kommunalen spitzenverbände die
das fordern auf die hilfsorganisation
wie die diakonie auf die länder und auf
ihren koalitionspartner denn die alle
wissen aus gutem grund warum sie diesen
gipfel fordern und das ist keine zeit
des abwartens das ist auch keine zeit
für befindlichkeiten einer ministerin
sondern es ist eine zeit des handelns
bitte handeln sie hier endlich
und wirklich große sorge bereitet mir
der umgang der ampel mit dem
bevölkerungsschutz am dienstag sagte
bundesfinanzminister lindner hier an
dieser stelle ich zitiere aus dem
protokoll fraglos ist der zivilschutz im
kern natürlich eine aufgabe der länder
nein liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
ist fraglos falsch gemäß artikel 73
nummer 1 des grundgesetzes ist der
zivilschutz ausschließlich aufgabe des
bundes und der bund unterstützt die
länder auch im katastrophenfall und
da muss ich mich wirklich wunder nach
zwei jahren corona nach der flut und
jetzt nach der wirklich erschreckenden
bedrohungen durch bedrohung durch
russland ist diese ahnungslosigkeit des
bundesfinanzministers in keinster weise
mehr nachvollziehbar
sie fordern zu recht dass die bundeswehr
mit 100 milliarden euro gestärkt wird
das ist gut das ist richtig und das ist
wichtig aber das bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz ist mindestens auch
wichtig wenn nicht ebenso wichtig weil
es die zweite seite der medaille der
äußeren und inneren sicherheit darstellt
das bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz
wird mit mickrigen zehn millionen euro
im zweiten entwurf jetzt zusätzlich
gefördert das bedeutet armin schuster
der präsident des bbk hat 135 millionen
angekündigt die braucht er noch um alles
das was wir auch in der letzten
legislaturperiode beschlossen haben
umzusetzen er bekommt zusätzlich zehn
millionen das ist viel zu wenig und
reicht gerade einmal um waren sms zu
versenden
sie investieren kein zusätzlichen euro
in sirenen in die nina war nett in die
nationale reserve für trinkwasser
notstrom gesundheit und notunterkünfte
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das ist
fahrlässig und wir haben doch gesehen
was wir brauchen wir brauchen ein
resilienz deutschland wir haben hier im
vergangenen jahr in der letzten
legislaturperiode die neuausrichtung des
bbk mit seiner zentrale stellen funktion
beschlossen und wenn sie wollen dass
dieses amt das auch umsetzen kann dann
braucht es verdammt noch mal eine
bessere finanzielle grundausstattung und
schaden den bevölkerungsschutz
ich bitte sie dringend an der stelle
nachzubessern
dringend und ich will noch drei punkte
zum abschluss sagen wenn sie es ernst
meinen mit der zivilen verteidigung mit
der warnung mit der neuausrichtung des
bbk und seine zentralstellen funktion
dann brauchen wir für die nächsten zehn
jahre ein sonder volumen von mindestens
10 milliarden euro und deshalb bitte ich
sie alle nachdrücklich wir müssen an
dieser stelle nachbessern für ein
zivilschutz und einen besseren
bevölkerungsschutz in deutschland danke
schön
die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der unions fraktion
andrea lindholz er war das
und das präsidium hat gewechselt
wolfgang kubicki hat hier die leitung
übernommen
[Musik]
die kollegin janina schäfer bündnis 90
die grünen das wort
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
die herausforderung der innenpolitik in
den letzten jahren waren oft größer als
der politische wille sie wirklich
anzugehen sei es zum beispiel eine
lösungsorientierte migrationspolitik der
kampf gegen rechtsextremismus oder ein
wirksamer zivilschutzes super dass die
da jetzt mehr tun wollen das hätten sie
natürlich auch schon in den letzten 16
jahren machen können
die neue regierung ist angetreten um das
zu ändern wir wollen ein vorbereiteter
und ein anpacken das start sein und der
vorliegende haushalt des
innenministeriums zeigte das
selbstvertrauen und auch den politischen
willen zum anpacken schwarz auf weiß in
der migrationspolitik haben wir die
ideologische sackgasse der letzten jahre
endlich hinter uns gelassen nämlich dem
trugschluss dass die bekämpfung von
migration politische handlungsfähigkeit
sei aber wer suggeriert dass man in
einer krisengebeutelten welt migration
einfach so ausknipsen kann der wird
stets an der realität scheitern
um die herausforderung wirklich
anzupacken müssen der migration als
realität anerkennen und selbstbewusst
gestalten
die gesellschaft ist hier schon lange
weiter als die politik ist der letzten
jahre gewesen ist die zivilgesellschaft
war es doch die wir schaffen das
geschafft hat aber
darauf darf sich der staat jetzt
natürlich durchaus und bund und länder
dürfen die kommunen und auch die
freiwilligen nicht im stich lassen neben
besseren strukturen für die erstaufnahme
und versorgung geht es jetzt darum
allen bei uns ankommenden menschen mit
integrationskursen und
integrationsangeboten zur seite zu
stehen zu ihrer ausfinanzierung werden
wir bis in den ergänzungs haushalt
hinein das notwendige tun
[Applaus]
damit unterbrechen weil ich gerne den
justizminister und frau kühn das bitten
würde ihre gespräche außerhalb des
plenarsaals fortzusetzen die ard hat
sich schon beschwert zu recht dass sie
gestört wird und es ist auch optisch
nicht sehr klug
frau kollegin sie haben das wort
entschuldigung noch ein versäumnis
müssen wir korrigieren
während rechtsextreme gewalttaten immer
mehr geworden sind und die
radikalisierung
antidemokratischer gruppen zugenommen
hat haben die innenminister in der
vergangenheit oft weggesehen und
verharmlost aber diese verharmlosung
habt rechten netzwerken viel raum
gegeben und eine massive
sicherheitslücke erzeugt der nsu die
anschläge in halle in hama und auch der
mord an walter lübke das ist nur die
spitze des eisbergs des menschen
verachten rechtsterrorismus in
deutschland aber ich kann ihnen sagen
die zeiten der bagatellisierung sind
vorbei
diese bundesregierung übernimmt
verantwortung und hat den kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus endlich zur zentralen
priorität deutscher innenpolitik gemacht
damit setzt die ministerin face die
richtigen schwerpunkte vielen dank dafür
es ist gut dass die experten und
expertinnen unserer behörden und vor
allem im bundesinnenministerium in
diesem bereich vermehrt und verstärkt
werden sollen die bundeszentrale für
politische bildung fördert die
medienkompetenz umfeld muss zu entlasten
und die gesellschaftliche resilienz zu
stärken durch den kreml gesteuerte des
informations und hasskampagnen im netz
sind zu einem fall beeinflussen faktor
im westen geworden deshalb ist jeder
euro der in projekte gegen
rechtsextremismus
gesteckt wird ein beitrag zur
internationalen widerstandsfähigkeit von
demokratien gerade im globalen system
wettbewerb und das müssen wir weiter
ausbauen
ich finde es sehr gut dass wir im
kontext von putins angriffskrieg jetzt
endlich über den zivilschutz sprechen
das ist längst überfällig
das zeigen auch schon der
fehlgeschlagene wahltag 2020 und die
flutkatastrophe im letzten sommer die
katastrophenhilfe und der zivilschutz
wurden in den letzten jahren wirklich
gefährlich vernachlässigt und das lag
auch ehrlich gesagt daran dass in der
union oft sicherheit beim militär
aufgehört hat und genau dieses verkürzte
sicherheitsverständnis ist ein
sicherheitsrisiko
und auch hier dürfen wir uns nicht auf
der arbeit der ehrenamtlichen ausruhen
denn die funktioniert genau dann am
besten wenn es eine professionelle
struktur gibt die ansprechbar ist und
die den überblick behält thw rotes kreuz
und die freiwilligen feuerwehren haben
immer wieder großartiges geleistet aber
wir brauchen ein starkes bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
als zentrale koordinierungsstelle
ja und geeignet das gerät und auch eine
angemessene personelle ausstattung
brauchen im haushalt eine entsprechende
finanzierung wir haben jetzt viel schon
über die bundeswehr und deren stärken
gesprochen aber im notfall ist es eben
auch wichtig dass wir unsere
zivilbevölkerung im katastrophenfall
schützen und auch versorgen können also
setzen wir die seit einem jahr
vorliegende neuausrichtung des
bundesamts für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe jetzt endlich in die
realität um ich komme zum schluss liebe
kollegen
wir dürfen keine angst vor den
innenpolitischen herausforderungen der
vergangenen jahre haben der vorliegende
haushalt gibt uns die mittel und den
rahmen an die hand um diese endlich
anzugehen nutzen wir sie vielen dank
[Applaus]
thomas schäfer war dass sie ist mitglied
im haushaltsausschuss und für die grünen
auch die berichterstatterin für diesen
etat nächster redner ist markus bühl
auch er setzt im haushaltsausschuss ist
mitglied der fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident sehr geehrte damen und
herren wenn man haushalt für
innenpolitik und heimat hört klingt das
erst mal sehr gut das hört sich nach
steuermitteln für den schutz unserer
heimat an und nach allen erforderlichen
maßnahmen zur sicherheit unserer bürger
die realität frau ministerin sieht
leider ganz anders aus angefangen beim
völlig unzureichenden grenzschutz viel
zu wenigen neuen bundespolizisten
mangelhaften katastrophenschutz oder dem
geplanten absinken des gesamthaushaltes
um gleich bei den tragischen ereignissen
der letzten wochen zu bleiben die
bundespolizei muss an den grenzen genau
kontrollieren können wer ein echter
flüchtling ist oder ein trittbrettfahrer
das leid
das leid der flüchtenden ukraine darf
nicht als einfallstor einer
unkontrollierten einwanderung nach
deutschland missbraucht werden und jetzt
wo wir so viele frauen kinder und
familien zeitweise unterbringen müssen
endlich alle ausreisepflichtigen und
abgelehnten asylbewerber der vergangenen
jahre abgeschoben werden
frau ministerin während polen
vorbildlich flüchtlinge registriert
scheitert die deutsche regierungspolitik
schon wieder bei der konsequenten
bekämpfung illegaler migration es mutet
geradezu absurd an aber unter anderem
aus schlichtem mangel an fingerabdruck
reden und der möglichkeit des abgleichs
unter den behörden bereits 2017 wurde
bekannt dass mehr als 90 prozent der
ausländerbehörden fingerabdrücke nicht
elektronisch abgleichen können ein
völlig unhaltbarer zustand
bleiben wir beim thema innere sicherheit
1000 zusätzliche stellen bei der
bundespolizei sind ein anfang aber
zuerst kommt die ausbildung und erst in
drei jahren dann die eigentliche
verstärkung und vor allem in den
kommenden jahren geht jährlich ein
beträchtlicher teil der beamten in den
ruhestand insofern ist die netto
verstärkung nicht groß sondern
kompliziert hauptsächlich die
altersbedingten abgänge erschreckend
kommt hinzu die mittelfristige
finanzplanung ein absinken ich erwähnte
des bereits des haushalts für das
innenministerium bereits nächstes jahr
um 2,6 milliarden euro vorsieht von den
neuen polizisten die dieses jahr bei der
bundespolizei fertig ausgebildet sind
wir hatten viele in ballungszentren mit
hohen mieten versetzt mieten die sich
die jugendpolizei absolventen oft nicht
leisten können und so wohngemeinschaften
bilden oder lange strecken pendeln
müssen hier besteht dringender
handlungsbedarf für eine lösung und die
lösung heißt nicht dass die wohn
fürsorge des bundes wohnungen in den
ballungsgebieten zu den gleichen hohen
mieten anbietet kombination ein paar
punkten bei der sachausstattung unsere
sicherheitskräfte die im letzten jahr
gestartete und von uns in der letzten
legislatur bereits intensive und
intensiv unterstützte auslieferung des
neuen modularen körper schutzes begrüßen
wir ausdrücklich es bleibt zu hoffen
dass die flächendeckende ausstattung
zügig erfolgt die umsetzung der vom
parlament bereits im jahr 2019
beschlossen um flotten der transport
hubschrauber der bundespolizei schleppt
sich dahin eine vergabe des auftrags ist
nach fast dreijähriger dauer noch immer
nicht erfolgt dabei müssen die fast 40
jahre alten transporthubschrauber sehr
dringend ersetzt werden beim digital
ausbau hinken wir anderen ländern um
viele jahre hinterher viel zu oft
funktioniert der digitalfunk bei
polizeilichen einsatzlagen nicht
störungsfrei bei den
bereitschaftspolizisten der länder sind
die ausrüstungen oft nicht kompatibel
und gleichwertig wodurch gemeinsame
einsatzlagen mit der bundespolizei ganz
erheblich erschwert werden es gibt viel
zu tun frau ministerin ich freue mich
auf die kommenden haushaltsverhandlungen
in denen wir uns mit unseren anträgen
für die innere sicherheit stark machen
werden um deutschland vom kopf zurück
auf die füße der innenstange für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank dafür gebühren
[Applaus]
nicht erhöht dass der kollege dr
thorsten lieb fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
willkommen zurück wir haben sie vermisst
schön sie wiederzusehen
sehr geehrte frau bundesgericht
der geehrte frau bundesministerin caesar
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen vor
wenigen tagen habe ich das
gemeindezentrum der jüdischen gemeinde
in frankfurt am main besucht direkt
neben dem gemeindezentrum befindet sich
eine grundschule auch eine kita ist dort
untergebracht ist ein deutliches zeichen
für die aktivität der gemeinde aber
jedes mal wenn man da vorbeigeht es ist
ausgesprochen erdrückend die
fortbestehende notwendigkeit von
sicherheitseinrichtungen
immer wieder stelle ich mir die frage
wie fühlt sich das an für die kinder und
jugendlichen jeden tag in einer solchen
situation in schule und kita zu kommen
das ist leider weiter notwendig ist
zeigt eine aktuelle studie es ist
erschütternd zu lesen dass rund ein
drittel der jungen erwachsenen und 30
jahre in diesem land antisemitisch
denken trotz aller anstrengungen 75
jahre nach dem ende des zweiten
weltkrieges und dem holocaust ist es
nicht gelungen das gespenst des
antisemitismus aus diesem land endgültig
zu vertreiben
deswegen sage ich eines klar solange
irgend eine jüdische einrichtung oder
institution in diesem land noch diese
art von sicherung benötigt so lange muss
uns klar sein dass diese zentrale
herausforderung bei uns auf der
tagesordnung bleibt deswegen müssen wir
alle gemeint mit aller kraft tag für tag
gegen antisemitismus kämpfen
derzeit
deshalb bin ich der regierung und der
ministerin ausgesprochen dankbar dass
das nicht nur ein lippenbekenntnis ist
sondern diese notwendigkeit des handelns
klaren fußabdruck im etat zeigt nämlich
insbesondere durch die konkret
angekündigte ausfinanzierung der
umfassenden maßnahmen mittel für
prävention zb umfang von mehr als zehn
millionen euro und ich freue mich sehr
darauf in der detaildiskussionen
gemeinsam dafür zu sorgen dass wir
effizient und zielgerichtet diese mittel
auf die straße wochen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
gerade gerade das bundesministerium des
innern zeichnet sich durch eine
besondere vielfalt der aufgaben aus
gesellschaftlicher zusammenhalt und
heimat und netzpolitik verfassung
verwaltungsmodernisierung die liste
lässt sich ja fast unendlich verlängern
jedes dieser zentralen themen für unsere
gesellschaft wäre einer eigenen debatte
heute heute wahrscheinlich wird aber in
den kommenden wochen haben wir dazu
reichlich gelegenheit vor allem aber der
ukraine krieg und die offenen aufgaben
im bereich katastrophen und
bevölkerungsschutz haben enorme
auswirkungen jetzt schon auf den
aktuellen etat erste antworten sind
schon drin dafür dafür haben wir zu
danken aber bewusst muss uns glaube ich
allen seien in diesem saal die die lage
ist dynamisch die lage wird sich
weiterentwickeln und natürlich können
wir stand heute noch nicht abschließend
etwas dazu sagen wohin uns die reise
führt und jeder der anderes formuliert
und glaubt und erwartete müssten heute
die abschließende aussage treffen der
hat die welt nicht verstanden der weiß
nicht wie die lage sich dynamisch
entwickelt
gerade
die fülle der aufgaben und der aktuellen
herausforderung macht es aber wichtig
auch zu fokussieren ich werde ein
augenmerk zum beispiel darauf legen die
anzahl von programmen mit den teilweise
ähnlichen zustellungen sehr genau auf
den prüfstand zu stellen dass wir die
ziele erreichen und bei den anstehenden
und dringend notwendigen
digitalisierungs aufgaben sage ich mit
über zehn jahren anwaltliche erfahrung
in it projekten da müssen wir sehr genau
hingucken projekte neigen gerne dazu
länger zu dauern und teurer zu werden
was wir aber wollen als ampel ist mit
jedem eingesetzten euro in diesem
bereich das maximum an digitalisierung
und verwaltungsmodernisierung
herauszuholen über freundin freuen
daneben muss natürlich der fokus ist es
schon angesprochen auf den aktuellen
herausforderungen liegen viele dinge
gucke in richtung der union sind zu
lange liegen geblieben großen
ankündigungen auf pressekonferenzen ist
wenig bis gar nichts gefolgt 16 jahre
unions geführtes innenministerium haben
mehr offene baustellen und mehr fragen
hinterlassen als das aufgaben erledigt
worden sind es doch die wahrheit und sie
hätten im ersten regierungsentwurf doch
die chance gehabt nachzuarbeiten das ist
doch unterkriegen wir packen das jetzt
an als ampel daher sind die zehn
millionen für das bbk genau richtig
investiert damit wir dort endlich einen
sprung nach vorne kommen es wird höchste
zeit keinen tag mehr wie 2020 darf uns
passieren frau ministerin
das bundesministerium des inneren trifft
besondere verantwortung für den
zusammenhalt der gesellschaft und für
die sicherheit in unserem land dafür
haben sie meine haben sie unsere
unterstützung ich freue mich auf die
zusammenarbeit herzlichen dank
vielen dank herr kollege
thorsten liebte war das und während hier
die abgeordneten im bundestag
diskutieren findet ja in brüssel wir
haben es angesprochen und auch gesehen
dass g 7 treffen statt das war bis 15
uhr 15 angekündigt danach sollte olaf
scholz ein statement abgeben sollte das
kommen dann werden wir dort live hin
schalten jetzt spricht hier im plenum
victor perli für die linksfraktion er
sitzt im haushaltsausschuss
vielen dank herr präsident meine damen
und herren durch den schlimmen krieg in
der ukraine sind millionen menschen auf
der flucht tausende kommen jeden tag
nach deutschland
wir erleben eine große welle der
solidarität aus der bevölkerung unter
den kommunen alle die sich hier eines
haben große anerkennung respekt verdient
herzlichen dank
dieser haushaltsentwurf im parlament
eine woche später vorgelegt wegen des
kriegsausbruchs dafür habe volles
verständnis wir haben kein verständnis
dafür dass nicht ein einziger
zusätzlicher euro hereingekommen ist um
die kommunen zu unterstützen die
flüchtlinge jetzt gut zu betreuen
die städte und kommunen und gemeinden
müssen bei der unterbringung der
geflüchteten komplett in vorleistung
getreten dabei hat der bund eigentlich
eine rücklage die sogenannte flüchtlings
rücklage um menschen in not zu helfen
ich habe mit mehreren bürgermeistern in
meiner heimat gesprochen in salzgitter
und wolfenbüttel diesen unzufrieden sie
mieten wohnungen an sie sorgen für
integration sich stellen personal ein
aber sie wissen nicht was sie bekommen
nicht vom bund nicht vom land frau
ministerin
warum haben sie nicht eine soforthilfe
bereitgestellt mit diesem
haushaltsentwurf um zu zeigen wir gehen
hier schnell voran wir möchten dass sie
alle mitmachen
komplett aus der zeit gefallen ist dass
in diesen haushalt sind wurf kürzungen
bei der integration vorgesehen sind zum
beispiel bei den integrationskursen das
muss zurückgenommen werden haben es
angedeutet dass das in diese richtung
geht das finden wir richtig es muss
erhöht werden genauso bei der
migrationsberatung bekommen briefe von
den wohlfahrtsverbänden die sagen wir
brauchen jetzt dringend mehr
unterstützung brauchen
planungssicherheit und wir finden als
linke die müssen sie auch bekommen mit
blick auf den krieg stellen sich jetzt
die bürgerinnen bürger fragen wie sind
wir eigentlich geschützt in einer
notsituation und angstfrei wie ist der
katastrophenschutz in meiner region
aufgestellt auch die krone pandemie und
die hochwasserkatastrophe im letzten
jahr haben gezeigt dass es viel
verbesserungsbedarf gibt es
war zum beispiel ein großer fehler das
ist natürlich auch ein ausdruck der
kaputt sparpolitik in diesem
liberalismus dass man vielerorts die
sirenen abgebaut hat was für ein
wahnsinns man jetzt wieder aufstellen
muss das war völlig falsch und wir haben
wir haben auch keine übersicht darüber
wo es welche mittel gibt das muss
dringend behoben werden sagt seehofer
oft angekündigt und es ist nicht
passiert ist darf nicht mehr
vernachlässigt werden wir brauchen ein
update beim bevölkerungs und
katastrophenschutz
meine damen und herren es ist
erschreckend dass inzwischen 600
neonazis per haftbefehl gesucht werden
die nsu mordserien der terroranschlag
eines nazis in hanau mannes darf nicht
weggeschaut werden hier muss konsequent
entwaffnet werden frau ministerin sie
haben einen sehr ambitionierten plan
vorgelegt wie sie gegen nazi strukturen
gegen rassismus gegen völkische
ideologie vorgehen möchten das begrüßen
wir ausdrücklich bewerben sie dabei
unterstützen auch mit eigenen
vorschlägen und hoffe dass wir das
beraten werden auch die
haushaltsberatungen und freue mich auf
eine gute und entschlossener klare kante
gegen rechts vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege berlin
[Applaus]
nächsten redner hören wir den kollegen
martin gerster spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident werte
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
ministerin nancy faeser ja es hat
wirklich lange gedauert aber jetzt steht
tatsächlich zum allerersten mal in der
geschichte unseres landes eine frau an
der spitze des bundesinnenministeriums
und zum ersten mal seit 16 jahren ist
die spd wieder direkt verantwortlich für
die innenpolitik des bundes und endlich
endlich ist es möglich zusammen mit den
grünen und auch mit der fdp so manche
innenpolitische weiche neu auszurichten
neu zu stellen viel zeit zur
einarbeitung die sonst übliche 100 tage
schonfrist gab und gibt es aber für die
neue ministerin nancy faeser und ihr
team nicht putins angriffskrieg bringt
viel leid für millionen menschen viele
tote verwundete und geflüchtete krieg
mitten in europa ich hätte mir das wie
so viele andere menschen überhaupt nicht
vorstellen können und daher machen sich
viele menschen auch große sorgen um die
sicherheit in europa und auch für die
innenpolitik in deutschland gibt es
immense herausforderungen eine davon
einige davon waren bereits vor
kriegsbeginn in der ukraine offenkundig
andere sind ganz neu hinzugekommen
orientierung klare haltung
handlungsstärke das ist jetzt gefragt
wenn sicherheit im wandel das gebot der
stunde ist und was sich jetzt schon
sagen lässt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen unsere bundesinnenministerium
nancy faeser ist ein gewinn für unser
land und die bundesregierung vom ersten
tag an hat sie sich vor ort einen
eindruck von den vielfältigen aufgaben
verschafft und zahlreiche gespräche
geführt bei der bundespolizei beim
technischen hilfswerk aber auch mit
ihren kollegen kollegen in den ländern
und in den eu-mitgliedsstaaten sie ist
präsent sie stellt sich den medien und
der öffentlichkeit sie erklärt ihre
politik und welche schritte jetzt
notwendig sind das war nicht immer so
aber das ist jetzt gerade in diesen
zeiten ganz besonders wichtig und es tut
gut daran daran weiter zu arbeiten ich
glaube wir sind ja auch dem sie es sehr
guten weg liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die ampel regierung die spd an der
spitze des bundesinnenministeriums dazu
noch eine frau böse gerüchte wurden in
die welt gesetzt dass jetzt im haushalt
des bundesinnenministeriums
übels gekürzt werden würde der
überarbeitete
regierungsentwurf liegt nun vor und
siehe da das gesamtvolumen des einzel
plans liegt bei 15 milliarden euro das
ist wenn man den baubereich
herausrechnet neue rekord ein zuwachs
von 844 millionen euro außerdem sieht
der entwurf
1660 zusätzliche stellen vor ich finde
ein sehr gutes verhandlungsergebnis das
uns hier vorgelegt wurde für die
weiteren haushaltsberatungen
vor allem die bundespolizei profitiert
vom stellen aufwuchs das ist wie ich
finde enorm wichtig unsere
bundespolizistin und bundespolizisten
leisten seit jahren nahezu unglaubliches
in einsätzen verschiedenster art ich
denke da vor allem aber nicht nur an die
einsätze in zusammenhang mit den
demonstrationen und so genannten
spaziergängen gegen die korona politik
zu recht stehen rund 1000 zusätzliche
stellen für die bundespolizei im
haushalt sind das ist eine klare
botschaft wie ich finde wertschätzung
und entlastung für unsere polizeikräfte
die für uns rechtsstaat und demokratie
verteidigen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
was für uns als spd fraktion aber auch
für mich persönlich und ich habe es
jetzt auch in den redebeiträgen von
llambi la cheffe und im kollegen
thorsten lieb gehört was uns hier freut
ist dass wir in diesem regierungsentwurf
auch eine neue schwerpunktsetzung
vorfinden die bekämpfung von
rechtsextremismus
ist jetzt sache der chefin
das zeigt sich in dem neuen aktionsplan
den die innenministerin vor wenigen
tagen persönlich vorgestellt hat und
auch im haushaltsentwurf die
bundesregierung hat er ja im letzten
jahr schon ein paket auf den weg
gebracht um entschieden gegen rechte
gewalt gegen rassismus gegen hetze und
hass im netz und auf der straße vorgehen
zu können die wehrhafte demokratie
braucht aber aus meiner sicht nicht nur
beschlüsse sie braucht auch mittel und
die sind jetzt in diesem
haushaltsentwurf endlich sichtbar und
das ist auch gut so liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der bevölkerungs und
katastrophenschutz aber auch dem
zivilschutz in der zivilverteidigung
kommt immer größere bedeutung zu
starkregen stromausfälle und einige
andere szenarien erfordern eine größere
aufmerksamkeit das ist vollkommen
richtig beim thw beim bbk sieht der
regierungsentwurf mehr mittel und auch
mehr personal vor sehr gut aber die
frage ist in der tat für die anstehenden
haushaltsberatungen
ob wir nicht noch mehr tun müssen um den
neuen herausforderungen gerecht zu
werden zum glück können wir auch viele
ehrenamtliche und hauptamtliche
einsatzkräfte bauen die immer zur stelle
sind wenn andere hilfe brauchen dafür an
dieser stelle ein dankeschön und zwar
wirklich von herzen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
diese regierungsentwurf ist bekanntlich
vor dem angriff putins auf die ukraine
erarbeitet worden cyber angriffe und das
informationskampagnen der zivilschutz
neue aufgaben um unsere bevölkerung zu
schützen erfordern bei unseren
haushaltsberatung eine neue
prioritätensetzung das haben schon
einige vor mir angesprochen vor allem
aber denke ich für die große zahl an
geflüchteten aus der ukraine brauchen
wir schutz unterstützung und integration
deshalb gilt es jetzt zügig deutschkurse
und kinderbetreuung zu organisieren und
berufsabschlüsse schneller anzuerkennen
und ich finde auch der sport kann
menschen unkompliziert zusammen zu
bringen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren sehr geehrter herr präsident ich
sie schon sie wollen wir ins wort fallen
letzter satz sicherheit im wandel
bedeutet dass wir unsere demokratie und
unseren rechtsstaat verteidigen gegen
extremisten dass wir diejenigen
wertschätze unterstützen die sich
hauptamtlich und ehrenamtlich jeden tag
aufs neue für unsere sicherheit
einsetzen und dass wir denjenigen schutz
und zuhause bieten die jetzt vor krieg
und zerstörung fliehen mussten und
müssen herzlichen dank
martin gerster war das uns diesen
mittlerweile ein signal aus brüssel wo
wir olaf scholz bundeskanzler erwarten
nach der untere mühle mit den g 7
staaten und auch nach dem datum geben
will wollte er sich bei ihr in kürze
äußern
im bundestag spricht nun mechthilde
wittmann es ist ihre erste rede diese
halten wird sie ist mitglied der
herr präsident frau bundesministerin
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn wir heute
über den haushalt des innenministeriums
reden dann reden wir über eigentlich
einen der relevantesten haushalte die
wir hier zu besprechen haben denn wir
reden darüber dass die sicherheit in
unserem land gewährleistet wird für
unsere bürgerinnen und bürger und gerade
auch für diejenigen die jetzt in die
sicherheitszone zu uns flüchten und
deswegen sollten wir diesen haushalt
ganz besonders ernst nehmen und
ich freue mich frau bundesministerin
dass der haushalt eine hohe kontinuität
aufweist zu den haushalten die in den
letzten jahren aufgewachsen sind die
frau kollegin in holz ja bereits
mitgeteilt hat und ausgeführt hat sie
weisen auf steigerungen im
personalbereich genauso wie in den
ausgaben die wir auf die verschiedenen
politikfelder legen und damit machen sie
eigentlich ein kompliment an die
vorgängerregierungen die damit nämlich
genau das auf gewissen haben worauf sie
aufbauen können sie haben ein
wohlbestelltes haus vorgefunden und wir
sind an ihrer seite wenn sie es in
gleicher art und weise weiterführen
und entgegen dem gelächter dass sich in
der mitte des hauses mal wieder auf tut
kann dieses alles auch mit zahlen
unterlegt werden die
kriminalitätsstatistik sagt uns ganz
eindeutig dass sie nahezu jedem
straftatbestand die zahlen
kontinuierlich nach unten gehen daran
wollen wir gemeinsam weiterarbeiten und
wir wollen uns eine sache noch mal
besonders angenehm ich da wo sie steigen
die straftaten steigen dort wo digitale
bezug da ist und sie steigen überall
dort wo sexuelle motivation im haus im
raum steht insbesondere bei kindern und
da sollten wir keine gelegenheit
auslassen es gemeinsam anzupacken
dagegen 40
kolleginnen und kollegen lassen sie uns
aber auch auf den aktuell brennendsten
punkt den wir haben ein gehen die frage
der migration und vor allen dingen die
frage der flug zu finden wir bei uns
denn das ist nicht die migration die wir
aus 20.15 kennen das ist eine
notsituation in der wir gehalten sind
allen allen zu helfen die jetzt kommen
und zunächst auch schlicht nur deswegen
weil sie in not geraten sind und
unabhängig davon wie ihr ursprünglicher
status war und dafür glaube ich haben
wir am anfang die lage unterschätzt und
von ministerin damals dann leider auch
mit der einigkeit da haben ob sie die
lange unterschätzt ich denke an unsere
sondersitzung im innenausschuss am 93
als sie noch davon sprachen dass es eine
registrierung so gar nicht nötig wäre
und dass der königsteiner schlüssel
nicht benötigt würde weil die länder
würden ja auf zuruf sagen sie hätten
noch kapazitäten ja klar was mache ich
denn wenn akut geflohen wird natürlich
sage ich da kriege ich noch eine tonale
her und das schaffen wir schon im
übrigen schaffen ist der ehrenamtlichen
und schaffen es will ich einmal hier
erwähnt haben die vielen schon seit
monaten überlasteten angestellten und
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in den
kommunen dort wird es geschafft
und sie haben auch gespannt nach der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am 17 denn
seither wird ja faktisch der
königsteiner schlüssel angewendet ja im
moment das mittel der wahl ist
gleichwohl man das sicher auch noch
einmal nachjustieren könnte und dabei
hätten wir das ganze so einfach haben
können es beginnt mit der zusammenarbeit
mit polen an den außengrenzen der
anderen staaten zur ukraine dort kommen
die menschen an und werden systematisch
registriert was hindert uns daran dort
mit den grenzbehörden zusammenzuarbeiten
digitale schnittstellen zu schaffen und
verbindungsbeamte zu schaffen so wie
wir's an den österreichisch deutschen
grenze der ausbruch gefahren haben bis
heute ist dazu nichts passiert ist wir
nichts 40 busse und bahnen habe die
eingestellt sind sondern muss sich auch
kollegen in holz wissen warum fahren sie
ab wo fahren sie hin mein potenzial das
wissen die vor ort nämlich so und so oft
gar nicht um eine andere hätte erzählen
mir dass schwierige sachen und wenn wir
davon ausgehen dass wir immer noch nicht
wirklich fürs registrieren das tun wir
nämlich nicht sondern wir greifen auf
das ungeliebte mittel der
schleierfahndung in wirklichkeit zurück
die bundespolizei geht in die züge und
versucht aufzunehmen wir erwischen aber
nicht die die natürlich beginnen dieses
mittel auch ein stück für sich
auszunutzen und die wollen wir als erste
erwischen
und ich möchte noch ein weiteres ganz
kurz anwendet sie haben in einem
interview gesagt es würde vor ort hat
man bei den ausländerbehörden das kann
ich so nicht stehen lassen ich möchte
noch mal sagen ich bedanke mich bei den
kommunen und den ehrenamtlichen sie aber
in perfekt an den hand von bund nach
unten zur landung vom juni kann ich das
nicht fest
und lassen sie mich ein letztes
anstrengen die frage des extremismus
vollkommen zu recht sagen sie dass sie
dies mit großem mitteln unterlegt haben
und wir sind dann mir das leid und das
haben alle denen in den letzten jahren
auch für die vorhergehende
bundesregierung jeweils getan aber sind
sie bitte nicht blind und ich habe das
heute mit freude gehört bei der frage
des linksextremismus und auch des
islamistischen und da muss ich einfach
noch ein wort sagen lebens extremismus
richtet sich fast immer gegen unsere
polizeibeamten und das gilt es zu
schützen diese gilt es zu schützen zur
insbesondere auch voraussagen eine
bundesministerin dies als form des
zivilen ungehorsam als legitim
betrachtet da sind sie nicht bei ihnen
und ich danke ihnen
vielen dank frau
kollegin widmen
gegnerin ist die kollegin julia görges
hat als sprecherin für inneres und
heimat für ihre fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen essen szenen
die ich nicht vergessen werde und ich
möchte diese gerne hier mit ihnen teilen
hauptbahnhof berlin freitagnachmittag
hände an der sitzungswoche vor mir an
die junge frau mit einem säugling im
wagen sie kann die abteile nicht finden
mehrere taschen hängen an ihr zu beginn
zu schwitzen die reihe die reihung der
waggons hat sich verändert die db hat
das auch schon durch gesagt aber wie
soll sie das verstehen ihr ticket nun
das abteil wollen einfach nicht
zusammenpassen ihr säugling schreit und
sie kann einfach nicht mehr zumindest
denke ich dass ihr fehlt sichtlich ein
stein vom herzen als ich sie auf
englisch frage ob hier helfen kann
sie muss ein paar abteile weiter sie
rechnet mich an und geht man vom dank
was denke ich bei mir
wenn ich das wäre mir meinen kindern an
der hand in einem fremden land in einem
fremden zug ein paar habseligkeiten dich
retten konnte zusammengerafft in einer
tasche mein mann zu hause geblieben um
deutschland zu verteidigen in welches
land wirklich überhaupt gehen wer würde
mir helfen
systemwechsel zu hause angekommen in
duisburg mein nachbar frührentner ist
ehrenamtlich beim thw aktiv er möchte
nach polen fahren um dort direkt zu
helfen seine frau will ihn auf keinen
fall fahren lassen sie hat angst um ihn
meine damen und herren sie hat
angefangen man nach polen will europa
wir sprechen hier von europa wir erleben
gerade tektonische verschiebungen in
sicherheit also die sicherheit und den
wir uns zu sehr wähnten ein
zerbrechliches gut ich bin den
ehrenamtlichen ehrenamtlichen helfern
und helfen so dankbar für die
selbstverständlichkeit mit der sie
helfen die polizistinnen und polizisten
den thw mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeitern
auch mitarbeiter und mitarbeitern von
städten und gemeinden
wir stimmen gerade als land
und als regierung eine menge und ich bin
es möchte ich einmal deutlich sagen
beeindruckt von meinem land und ja
dankbar dass wir das so hinkriegen auch
sehr dankbar darüber dass wir für die
aufnahme von kriegsflüchtlingen eine
europäische einigung herbeigeführt haben
so geht europa es ist unser europa und
gut möglich dass dieses europa den kreml
überrascht hat und wenn dem so ist dann
ist es gut
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
und doch der russische angriffskrieg
gegen die ukraine stellt uns nicht nur
international ganz anders als in den
letzten jahrzehnten vor immense
herausforderungen was heißt das
eigentlich für eine vorausschauende
innenpolitik wir brauchen eine nationale
sicherheitsstrategie die an erweiterten
sicherheitsbegriff zur grundlage hat und
ich bin dem bundeskanzler sehr dankbar
dass er gestern hier im hohen haus von
verteidigung und sicherheit sprach wir
können und dürfen militärische
verteidigung nicht ohne die zivilen
krisenschutz für die menschen in unserem
land denkt
die vergangenen tage haben auch gezeigt
in der ukraine handelt es sich nicht nur
um eine militärischen krieg sondern auch
um einen informations krieg der im
digitalen raum ausgefochten wird gegen
hybride angriffe sollten wir gewappnet
sein möglicher beeinträchtigungen der
kritischen infrastruktur auch durch
cyber-angriffe müssen ernst genommen
werden dazu gehören ein möglicher
ausfall der strom und wasser oder
wärmeversorgung wärmeversorgung wir
wollen eine strategische neuausrichtung
zügige umsetzung der konzeption zivile
verteidigung stellen wir uns nur ein
stromausfall in einer großstadt wie
hamburg und in meinem wahlkreis duisburg
vor nur drei tage ohne strom würden uns
lagen chaos erzeugen wir müssen schnell
reagieren können wir müssen handeln
bevor so etwas passiert nicht wenn so
etwas passiert
hier geht es aber auch nicht um
panikmache aber kluge politik handelt
vorausschauend deshalb gehen wir mit
klarem blick geben mit klarem blick
unsere neuen aufgaben an es ist daher
genau richtig dass sie frau
bundesinnenminister feser bereits
angekündigt haben den zivilschutz
auszubauen jetzt gilt es das bundesamt
für sicherheit in der
informationstechnik unabhängiger zu
stellen das bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz
braucht eine massive personelle und
materielle stärkung das bwk muss eine
zentrale stelle sein um sich an
veränderte lagen schnell anpassen zucker
auch das thw steht bereit seine aufgabe
umfassend zu erfüllen und wo nötig
anzupassen zum beispiel über die
lebensmittel bevorratung die zentral
organisiert gehört die resilienz
fähigkeit ist für unsere hoch
technologisierten gesellschaft einfach
zentral und zwar nicht nur beim
zivilschutz es ist ein trauerspiel wie
die behörden die im ernstfall geolino
schutzpflichten des staates umsetzen
müssen in den vergangenen jahren vom
zuständigen csu geführten haus klein
gehalten und personell abgekämpft wurden
wie konnte das geschehen möchte man an
dieser stelle herrn seehofer fragen aber
sie lassen ihr dass sie werde aller
voraussicht nach nicht allen geschätzte
kolleginnen und kollegen die russische
invasion der ukraine hat auch durch
desinformation und cyberattacken
ernstzunehmende bedrohungslage
geschaffen aber hybride angriffe sind
nicht erst ein problem
sind nicht erst ein problem seit beginn
des blutigen krieges
sofort herr präsident aber
eines ist aber auch klar demokratie
feinde mit zugang zu informationen
waffen und munition extremisten
jeglicher art vision nicht diener dieses
staates sei auch jeder einzelfall ist
einer zu viel und das werden wir nicht
dulden und wo nötig auch das dienstrecht
anpassen
und der nächste
fraktion
christian wirth ist das mitglied im
innenausschuss
[Applaus]
herr präsident werde kollegin der große
wurf ist der ampelkoalition mit dem
einzelplan und 6 des innenministeriums
erwartungsgemäß nicht gelungen die
drängendsten probleme unseres landes
möchte auch die neue bundesregierung
nicht anpacken der kriegen der ukraine
seine folgen zeigen uns in vielen
bereichen die fehlentwicklung der
deutschen innenpolitik auf und in kaum
einem so deutlichen maße wie in der
asyl- und migrationspolitik sei der
merkelschen grenzöffnung haben sich
hunderttausende ausreisepflichtige in
deutschland festgesetzt fährt wertvolle
kapazitäten die wir nun dringend für
tatsächlich hilfsbedürftige ukrainische
frauen kinder und greise gebrauchen
könnten hier bedürfe es dringend einer
nationalen kraftanstrengung und
geltendes recht endlich umzusetzen
im bereich des grenzschutzes unter
bundespolizei offenbart sich ebenfalls
ausstellungs bedarf nach einschätzung
des vorsitzenden der
bundespolizeigewerkschaft
hypotheken höchstens 60 prozent der über
polen einreißen flüchtlinge kontrolliert
eine chance die von vielen
drittstaatsangehörigen benutzt wird um
unerkannt unter den ukrainischen
flüchtlingen hier einzureisen um die
innere sicherheit ist es ebenfalls
schlecht bestellt ministerin feser wird
die augenmerk offenbar nur auf
vermeintlichen rechtsextremismus auf dem
linken auge ist sie völlig blind
islamischer terrorismus scheint nur
nebensache zu sein was wir dringend
bräuchten ist ein paradigmenwechsel der
deutschen innenpolitik stärkung der
inneren sicherheit durch aufstockung der
polizei und sicherheitsbehörden
konsequente abschiebung ausreicht so
wichtiger und effektiver grenze tollen
ein waschechter skandal ist es dass die
delius rasmus stiftung nicht bei den
global zuschüssen zur
gesellschaftspolitischen und
demokratischen bildungsarbeit bedacht
wurde es verstößt nicht nur gegen
höchstrichterliche rechtsprechung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts zur
gleichstellung
politischer strömungen 286 sondern auch
gegen die jahrzehntelang geübte praxis
des deutschen bundestages sie schaden
damit nicht nur um die von ihnen
beabsichtigt der ard sondern der
demokratie in unserem land
insgesamt es ist ein schlag ins gesicht
für millionen wähler und zeigt dass
ihnen selbst offenkundig rechtswidrige
verhalten zur sicherung der eigenen
macht legitim zu sein scheint man sollte
sich schämen wir sie zum schluss möchte
ich noch herhalten man briten einen
blick nur auf den einzelplan und 6 zu
werfen neuerdings wird er die ansicht
die volkszugehörigkeit sei nicht
identisch mit der staatsangehörigkeit
als verfassungsfeindlich eingestuft da
stolze stützung durch gehört nicht
zwingend deutsche volkszugehörigkeit
sein musst sieht man schon an der
finanziellen förderung
deutscher staatsbürger sorbischer
volkszugehörigkeit ebenfalls fördert das
bmi ausländische staatsbürger deutscher
volkszugehörigkeit
insbesondere in osteuropa
dies begrüßen wir selbstverständlich
ausdrücklich dies nur zu verdeutlichen
welch absurde
argumentationslinien die alternative für
deutschland in die vermeintliche
verfassungsfeindlichkeit gerückt werden
soll erhalten banken sei ebenfalls
empfohlen häufiger auf die zahlen des im
geschäftsbereich des bmi angeklickt und
statistischen bundesamtes zu vertrauen
neuerdings arbeitet arbeitet er allen
ernstes mit zahlen der durch annette
karl hahne geführte amadeu antonio
stiftung als sammelbecken ehemaligen sed
spitze und kommunisten fleisch ist das
ist der preis damit ein christ und grad
auch unter der ampel regierung weiterhin
das bundesamt befassung
verfassungsschutz führen darf wer weiß
im bundeshaushalt lehnen wir ab vielen
dank und gut auf
vielen dank herr kollege dafür wird
auf christian wirth folgten nun manuel
höferlin er ist der innenpolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident
der geehrte kolleginnen kollegen dieser
haushalt des innenministeriums zeigt vor
allem eins das zeigt einen
paradigmenwechsel der fortschritts
koalition in der innenpolitik sowohl
sachlich aber vor allen dingen auch im
stil meine damen und herren im stil
bedeutet das nämlich dass dieser
haushalt geprägt ist davon dass nicht
parteitaktisches aufrechnen sondern im
kern zusammenarbeit in der sache
stattfindet und dieser fortschritt
kommission möchte gemeinsam etwas für
die menschen und das land bewegen und
das ist gut so und das führt meine hand
herren am ende eben nicht auf ein stück
werk sondern auf ein gesamtwerk und ich
könnte jetzt leicht machen und mal breit
ausführen warum der fortschritt zu
dringend gebraucht wird was in den
letzten 16 jahren unter der union in
diesem innenpolitik falsch gemacht wurde
oder was gar nicht gemacht wurde aber
erstens liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wissen sie selbst das in die in der
politik in den letzten 16 jahren unter
ihm das nicht immer eine sternstunde war
vor allen dingen mit falschen
prioritätensetzung und zweitens möchte
ich doch lieber nach vorne schauen auf
das was wir machen können was unser land
vor weit voran bringt und was auch dem
fortschritt für die bürgerinnen und
bürger wirken kann und dafür müssen wir
lediglich mal schauen in welchen feldern
die fortschritts koalition mehr tut als
es bisher der fall war sehen wir zum
beispiel die mittel beim
bevölkerungsschutz ich sags mal so der
wahltag war im besten fall eine warnung
für uns die schreckliche katastrophe im
aartal und die auswirkungen waren auch
die folgen davon waren versäumnisse die
getan die einfach unterlassen wurden in
den letzten jahren im zivil- und
bevölkerungsschutz und der
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff russlands
auf die ukraine zeigt auch deutlich dass
wir darüber
hinausgehend auch noch den abbau des
zivilschutz der letzten jahre
vorangetrieben wurde und das muss sich
dringend ändern und damit gehen wir auch
in diesem haushalt einmal am tag und
zwar mit hochdruck
wenn ich so höre wusste sagte vöhringer
das alles zu wenig geld der
entscheidende punkt ist gerade beim
bevölkerungsschutz und beim zivilschutz
nun ganz klar sagen wir können nicht
einfach nur geld darauf schützen so wie
sie das problem in den letzten jahren
immer getan haben es uns löst sich von
alleine sondern gerade wenn
bevölkerungsschutz und beim zivilschutz
ist das problem dass die strukturen
nicht richtig gestimmt haben das nicht
klar war wer eigentlich wen anruft das
die organisation nicht ordentlich war
und ich habe das sehr interessiert
gehört von den trotz sie haben letztlich
ja zugesagt dass eine zentralstellen
funktion des bbk notwendig sei und ich
freue mich auf ihre unterstützung auch
die vorteile stützung der länder die
unter ihnen geführt sind wenn wir salz
wäre dafür eine grundgesetzänderung
brauchen damit hat danke ich für die
zusage von ihnen der union herzlichen
dank dafür
da ich nur drei minuten hat würde ich
sagen bevor der präsident nicht dazu
ermahnt das natürlich auch andere
bereiche wie zum beispiel die
transformation in der digitalisierung
dazu führen dass wir den cyber raum die
cybersicherheit voranbringen müssen wir
müssen die gesellschaftspolitik so
ausrichten dass wir extremismus jeder
art dort auch von allen akteuren
bekämpft werden eine starke prävention
vorangetrieben wird ich bin überzeugt
dass dieser haushalt fortschritt
bedeutet und die fortschritts koalition
finden gemeinsam nach vorne bringen
herzlichen dank
an höhe verlieren
ein
14,96 milliarden euro so steht es im
entwurf der bundesregierung soll das
bundesinnenministerium bekommen das sind
19 prozent weniger als im jahr 2021 denn
auch der bereich bauwesen ist nicht mehr
teil des innenministeriums dafür wurde
gegründet martina renner sprach jetzt
für den instruktionen ich fange mal mit
der haben seite an der entwurf des
haushaltes setzt ein positives signal
keine gelder für die extrem rechte die
sie der eos erasmus stiftung
rechte olivenöl und das licht aus
staatlichen mitteln finanziert werden
das muss auch in zukunft so bleiben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
rechtsextreme netzwerke zerschlagen
neonazis entwaffnen finanzströme rechte
akteure ausdrucken das sind die
forderungen die die linke ist seit
jahren vertritt mit der vorstellung des
aktionsplans gegen rechtsextremismus
diese forderung jetzt im
bundesministerium angekommen wir finden
das gut
aber gerade weil wir diese punkte seit
jahren fordern wissen wir auch dass
absichtserklärung alleine nicht reichen
es brauchte den willen diesen
aktionsplan auch durchzusetzen
und das kann nur gelingen wenn die
sicherheitsbehörden des bundes hier
mitziehen mehr geld mehr geld wird
alleine nicht automatisch zu besseren
ergebnissen führen wir fordern erstens
das geld zielgerichtet so einzusetzen
damit das bundeskriminalamt in die lage
versetzt wird rechtsextreme netzwerke
effektiv zu bekämpfen
das selbst vor allem eine bessere
fachspezifische ausbildung also im
ergebnis besser geschultes personal
voraus ich möchte ein bka das mit
energie die einfachste ermittler regel
verfolgt folge den waffen folge dem geld
wir fordern zweitens in zukunft keine
weiteren mittel aufwüchse für den
inlandsgeheimdienst
der inlandsgeheimdienst
war doch nur ein verbündeter beim kampf
gegen rechtsextreme netzwerke sondern
hat diese aktiv verhindert hat diesen
aktiv verhindert diesen kampf und
neonazis vor strafverfolgung geschützt
es geht das ist realität schauen sie mal
an die berichte der
untersuchungsausschüsse da können sie
das alles nachlesen und es geht
nicht um mehr geld ich wünsche mir eine
aufklärung darüber wie das ideologische
und organisatorische wirken von hans
georg maßen vielleicht heute noch die
arbeit des amtes bestimmt da braucht es
dringend einer magischen öffentliche
aufklärung
kollegen kommen sie wieder im plus
freundlicherweise zum schluss kommen
sie haben jetzt noch ein satz und dann
muss ich
präsident ich nehme jetzt auch die drei
sätze von spd und grünen
frau kollegin sind bereits 50 sekunden
über ihrer rede zurück sie haben sie
haben von den letzten satz vor gedacht
ich hoffe dass sie
gemeinsam mit uns
nicht nur den aktionsplan gegen
rechtsextremismus in die tat umsetzen
sondern auch bei dem versprechen kleiden
wie sie es im koalitionsvertrag
formuliert haben dass es keine mittel
für staatliche hacking tools gibt auch
das werden wir in zukunft sehr genau
verfolgen als opposition vielen dank
martina renner
das spreche für antifaschismus auch für
innenpolitik und wir warten weiterhin
auf das statement von bundeskanzler olaf
scholz das war um viertel nach drei
angekündigt allerdings wurde uns gesagt
dass er noch mit den staats und
regierungschefs der g 7 staaten zusammen
sitzt da besteht also mehr redebedarf
als ursprünglich geplant in der debatte
geht es jetzt weiter mit sebastian
hartmann sprecher für inneres der
sozialdemokrat
ich muss auch ausdrücken
aber ich wollte nur sagen die jetzt auch
so klatschen nicht auch für sie geht es
natürlich das abnehmen der basket
zunächst mit einem ordnungsruf bedacht
wird dann beim wiederholungsfall mit
einem ordnungsgeld es geht auch ums
vermittelt er meine eigene fraktion
nicht dass sie denken ich habe nur so
ein blick nach rechts ich gucke auch
nach links so
bat meine fraktion nicht links sitzend
über zu sein nächster redner ist der von
mir sehr geschätzte kollege sebastian
hallmann erst mit der fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren die der
regierungsentwurf liegt vor und
sicherheit ist das zentrale versprechen
eines modernen staates und darüber
werden wir in den nächsten wochen ringen
debattieren wenn es darum geht den guten
haushaltsentwurf dass unser haushalt
martin gerster auf den punkt gebracht
hat noch besser zu machen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben ja
auch einiges an vorschlägen schon
vernommen das wichtigste in anfang liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen diese
sicherheit steht im wandel wir sind mit
anderen herausforderungen konfrontiert
wenn wir die cyber lage betrachten wenn
wir die digitalen bedrohungslagen
unseres staates unserer gesellschaft
betrachten aber seit mehr als vier
wochen sind wir mit einer situation
konfrontiert die wir nicht geringer als
die größte humanitäre katastrophe auf
diesem europäischen kontinent seit ende
des zweiten weltkrieges betroffen und
wenn ich jetzt in richtung der cdu/csu
schau dann erlebe ich hier einiges an
vorwürfen in den raum gestellt worden
ist das will ich in aller deutlichkeit
sagen die nicht den hauch einer chance
des beweises haben dass sie der realität
entsprechen und sie so man sich fragen
ob sie angesichts dieser situation ihrer
rolle als konstruktive opposition
überhaupt gerecht werden wenn es hier
mit falschparkern kommen
ich kann ihnen ich kann ihnen versichern
das was ich hier machen ist eine trauma
aufarbeitung ihrer missglückten amtszeit
de maizière und horst seehofer wenn es
darum geht dass auf der einen seite von
angela merkel gesagt wird wir schaffen
das und der bayerische ministerpräsident
wenige wochen danach ruft es ist die
herrschaft des unrechts
frau kollegin ich sie und sie lassen der
kollege hat man offensichtlich
zwischenfrage auch zu dann bitte schön
präsidentin der hatte mich nicht ge sind
das vielfache winken vielen dank dass
sie die frage zu lassen weil sie dies so
begonnen haben normalerweise beginnt er
im ausschuss immer damit die opposition
also uns zu beschimpfen jetzt haben wir
es hier auch in der rede aber ist ihnen
bewusst dass wir in der sondersitzung
die ministerin gefragt haben ob sie sich
gedanken gemacht hat wie man das
effizient verteilt und sie uns gesagt
hat sie geht davon aus das funktioniert
im moment die länder nähmen das
freiwillig ab ist ihnen bewusst dass wir
im ausschuss in der sondersitzung
gefragt haben ob sie sich gedanken
gemacht hat bzw war dann nur noch der
staatsrat die ministerin war dann schon
weg über die kosten weil wir jetzt schon
wussten damals schon wussten dass die
kommunen fragen wer bezahlt das was
können wir anbieten und die antwort des
staatssekretärs war über so was müssen
wir uns jetzt noch keine gedanken machen
waren sie da anwesend und ist ihm
bewusst dass diese mehrere kern frank im
zusammenhang der bewältigung der
flüchtlingskrise da keine antworten
kamen durch sondern es löst sich alles
von alleine
liebe frau kollegin da wir gemeinsam an
allen ausschusssitzungen des
innenausschusses in der vergangenheit
teilgenommen haben was zumindest diese
wahlperiode angeht ist der letzte teil
ihrer frage ob wir gemeinsam anwesend
waren ja frage sie aber auch umgekehrt
frage sie aber umgekehrt ob ihnen
bewusst ist dass es einen erheblichen
unterschied zwischen der
iss ich frage sie umgekehrt ob es ihnen
bewusst ist dass es einen erheblichen
unterschied dazu gibt wie die vorgänger
von frau nancy faeser als
innenministerin mit der frage von flucht
und migration umgegangen sind ich
benenne namentlich thomas de maizière
ich benenne auch horst seehofer der in
den letzten zwei jahren der pandemie im
übrigen als zuständiger minister für den
bevölkerungsschutz vollkommen auf
tauchstation war vor kollege und wir
haben ein zwei lehren aus der aus der
lehre
2015/2016 gezogen und ich sage ihnen
ganz konkret erstens haben wir als
ampelkoalition auf eines geachtet dass
für die obleute und sprecher aller
fraktionen des innenausschusses in
regelmäßige lage briefings einbezogen
das gab es bei cdu/csu und nicht der
erste der zweite punkt ist im rahmen
dieser gespräche ist regelmäßig fragen
sie ihren sprecher ist in mindestens
drei besprechungen gemeinsam
durchgeführt wurde im rahmen dieser
besprechung ist dynamisch über die lage
informiert worden dass in den ersten
wochen sich das geschehen der migration
unterschiedlich verhalten hat zu dem
zweiten teil der mikro zu wir redeten zu
anfang über mehrere tausend und eine
große welle der freiwilligkeit wo länder
angeboten haben nachdem pletzing
verfahren wir bieten plätze an und wir
wollen keine verteilung haben als wir
feststellten dass bestimmte hot spots
entstanden sind wie berlin wie hamburg
und die länder auch deutlich auf den
bund zugegangen haben wir gesagt wir
müssen zu einer festen verteilung
übergehen dass es im rahmen dieser
besprechung auch angesprochen und
thematisiert wird wir sind das ist ein
zitat noch nicht an dem punkt der festen
zuweisung wir werden an diesem punkt
kommen dritter und letzter punkt
kollegin ist ihnen ist herr kollege uns
zu ich sage ihnen ist ihnen bewusst dass
er nun in rede stehende § 24 des
aufenthaltsgesetzes der novelliert
worden ist und auch entsprechend in das
deutsche recht eingefügt worden ist zu
zeiten der union in das aufenthaltsrecht
übernommen worden ist und die regelung
dort seit regierungswechsel nicht
verändert worden sind und die
kapazitäten der deutschen würden auch
nicht verändert das heißt sie tragen im
kern dafür verantwortung dass das recht
existiert und dass sie dieses auch
anwenden lassen es einen unterschied
gibt denn welcher auch noch erwähnen
müssen zur ostsee vor und thomas de
maizière nennt sich leser ist die erste
hin ministerin der es gelungen ist in
deutschland das alle europäischen
staaten an einem strang ziehen und nicht
der deutsche innenminister auf
tauchstation darf wenn angela merkel
sich gegen den rest der europäischen
staaten bestellten gesellschaft
verschaffen das und das ist ihre
verantwortung liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und das geht mir diese sonst
erwartet der im wasser aufnehmen sie
schauen sich nicht das projekt und der
geflüchteten
angefahren worden und kinder und
gebrechliche und sie diskutieren über
registrieren sie versuchen es
auseinanderzutreiben anstellen
zusammenstellen in dieser situation
unser land und diesen kontinent fordert
werden wir wollen nicht gerecht
und da die zeit weiter läuft machen wir
ein angebot an die union weil sie ja die
demokratische opposition sind wir können
das jetzt in jeder innenausschusssitzung
durchexerzieren sie haben 16 jahre lang
die verantwortung getragen sie haben es
doch nicht auf die kette bekommen sie
waren doch auf tauchstation und sie
versuchen jetzt das auseinander zu
treiben aber wir werden stärker sein
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen denn es
ist eine europäische ausschreibung und
es muss uns bewusst sein und da tu ich
mal ne ganz rechte ecke des hauses wenn
zwei reden jedesmal geflüchtete in den
mittelpunkt stellt und angebliche
trittbrettfahrer es nicht ein einziges
mal schafft putin der diesen
angriffskrieg führt und dass die rosa
liste verurteilt der verpasst etwas
und uns muss bewusst sein liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen jetzt ist die
stunde europas gekommen jetzt kommt es
darauf an dass wir gemeinsam diese
humanitäre katastrophe bewältigen und da
wären der haushaltsberatung sind und wir
wissen das ist ein tag vor dem angriff
gab und einen tag davor als der
regierungsentwurf eingebracht worden ist
müssen wir auch in aller offenheit sagen
frau lindholz ich habe es gehört aber
ich kann es ihnen auch noch mal erklären
wir müssen anerkennen dass der
regierungsentwurf von ihnen zunächst
eingebracht worden ist und vor uns
verbessert worden ist und er wird noch
mal besser weil es wird einen weiteren
schritt geben müssen sicherheit im
wandel braucht auch mehr investitionen
und die sind sie schuldig geblieben es
waren ihre innenministers waren ihre
finanzminister die personal abgebaut
mittel gekürzt haben und immer über die
schwarze null geredet habe aber zu
selten bei sicherheit liebe kollegen sie
sind verantwortlich dass der
bevölkerungsschutz in deutschland nicht
leistungsfähig war der wahltag war ihr
horst seehofer flop und nicht unsere und
das wird mich noch mal passieren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ganz einfach
weil jetzt korrigieren und sie in der
opposition sind und das haben die
wählerinnen und wähler entschieden
aber wir werden mehr an den zivilschutz
investieren müssen das sage ich ihnen zu
genauso wie die friedensdividende
verbraucht worden ist was die
streitkräfte angeht müssen wir mehr in
den bevölkerungsschutz mehr den
zivilschutz und mehr an den cyber schutz
und die cyber security investieren und
ich bin mir sehr sicher dass die ampel
koalition genau diesen weg in diesen
haushaltsberatung gehen wird liebe
kolleginnen kollegen und das sage ich
ihnen zu wenn sie dann doch an
konstruktiven beitragen indem sie zb auf
die länder an wirkung ein gemeinsames
wir schaffen das draus machen oder wenn
wir wirklich an die seite der länder
rücken wollen dann werden wir diese
krise auch gemeinsam bewältigen und ich
möchte mich an die mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger in diesem land wenn ich glaube
nicht dass uns noch bewusster wird wenn
wir sagen heute ist der tag des
waffenstillstandes in der ukraine und
wir hoffen auf diesen tag dass dieser
krieg endet aber die menschen die jetzt
schon nach europa geflohen sind
dreieinhalb millionen menschen stand
heute und da kommen noch millionen von
binnenvertriebenen
wer glaubt denn wirklich in diesem hohen
haus das mit dem tag millionen von
geflüchtete zurückgeben die ukraine wird
einen marshall plan brauchen zum
wiederaufbau wir werden erneut in
schulen in krankenhäuser alles zerstört
zerbombt investieren müssen und die drei
jahre die der temporären schutz jetzt
umfasst liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
sind erst der anfang es wird uns fordern
und das was passiert ist es im
zeitraffer das was
2015/2016 war binnen vier wochen lassen
sie uns als demokratischen kräfte in
diesem haus zusammenarbeiten
lasst uns dafür sorgen dass diese
gemeinsame aufgabe europas und
deutschlands bewältigt wird es seine
bund und länder aufgabe aber die kosten
dürfen nicht und das ist ein gemachter
fehler 2015 2016 erneut an den kommunen
hängen bleiben sie tragen die
hauptlasten dank an die ehrenamtlerinnen
und ehrenamt wir stehen an ihrer seite
der innenpolitische sprecher der spd
diese was den radlern hier auch mit
vielen angriffen gegen den ehemaligen
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer das
mit stephan mayer der neue
generalsekretär der csu hier sicherlich
kontern sprecher verstanden und ehrenamt
ist auch nach aber zunächst an einem
kindergarten von wolfgang kubicki das
ergebnis der wahl der mitglieder des
parlamentarischen kontrollgremiums ist
gemäss artikel 45 das wollen sie jetzt
bekannt zu geben und mich dabei
gleichzeitig bei den schriftführern
schutz sondern die diese auszählung
ari hinter sich gebracht haben war sehr
umfangreich dass sie das also gut
geleistete mitgliederzahl des deutschen
bundestags 736 abgegeben bestimmt garten
642 von den abgegebenen stimmen
entfielen auf die spd 529 jahre stimmen
68 nein-stimme 29 enthaltungen 16
ungültige stimmen auf sebastian hartmann
spd 526 jahre stimmen 72 nein-stimmen 31
enthaltungen 13 ungültige stimmen auf
den kollegen dr besteht in der spd 448
jahr stimmen 142 nein-stimmen 32
enthaltungen
und 20 ungültige stimmen und auf maria
lisa feller als spd-fraktion 55 28 ja
stimmen 65 nein-stimmen 33 enteilt
ehrungen und 16 ungültige stimmen den
kollegen alexander hoffmann cdu csu
fraktion den vielen 525 jahre stimmen 43
nein-stimmen 50 enthaltungen und 24
ungültige stimmen auf roderich
kiesewetter cdu csu fraktion 535 jahre
stimmen 40 nein stimmen 48 enthaltungen
und 19 ungültige stimmen auf die
kollegen christoph de vries die
csu-fraktion 503 ja-stimmen
58 nein stimmen 56 enthaltungen und 25
ungültige stimmen noch nie kollegin dr
irene mihalic 502 bündnis 90/die grünen
520 jahr stimmen einsätze nein-stimmen
32 enthaltungen und 19 ungültige stimmen
und die kollegen dort konstantin von
notz bündnis 90/die grünen 511 jahr
stimmen 78 nein-stimmen 35 enthaltungen
und 18 ungültige stimmen auf dem
kollegen konzerne coole fdp-fraktion
532 jahre stimmen 61 nein stimmen und 35
enthaltungen bei 14 ungültigen stimmen
auf den kollegen alexander graf
lambsdorff fdp fraktion 539 jahre
stimmen 51 nein-stimmen 38 erteilt und
14 ungültige stimmen auf den kollegen
joachim wundrak ag fraktion 90 jahre
stimmen 435 nein-stimmen 30 enthaltungen
und 87 ungültige stimmen und auf den
kollegen doktor andré hahn fraktion die
linke 341 jahre stimmen 180 nein-stimmen
72 enthaltungen und 49 ungültige stimmen
damit haben folgende abgeordnete
nachbar jedoch zwei auf drei das wären
über die parlamentarische kontrolle der
tätigkeit des bundes die erforderliche
mehrheit von 369 stimmen erreicht und
sind damit als mitglieder des
parlamentarischen betreut williams
gewählt
sebastian hartmann dr ralf stegner war
ja dieser völlers alexander hoffmann
roderich kiesewetter christoph de vries
dmx tochterkonzern von notz konstante
kohle und alexander graf lambsdorff
sie sind damit als mitglieder des
parlamentarischen verfahrens gewählt die
abgeordneten joachim wundrak und dr
andré hahn haben die erforderliche
mehrheit nicht erreicht und sind damit
nicht gewählt damit ist das ergebnis
festgestellt und das ist ein
überraschendes ergebnis meine damen und
herren denn andré hahn war bislang
mitglied im parlamentarischen kontrolle
sehen wir von den linken er hat die
mehrheit die nötig findet wer hat hier
wirklich nur knapp verpasst bei 100 von
der afg konnte man sicherlich davon
ausgehen und jetzt der förmlichen
angekündigte der sekretär der csu
gespart
gewissen und ihrem erinnerung vor allem
etwas auf die sprünge zu helfen es war
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer der
nach diesem schrecklichen attentat am 19
februar 2020 in hanaus sofort eine
außerordentliche innenministerkonferenz
initiiert hat und dann auf sein
betreiben hin 1 89 punkte programm zur
bekämpfung des rechtsextremismus der
bundesregierung auf den weg gebracht hat
es war die szene war er etwa vor einem
jahr mit dem bka-präsidenten ein zehn
punkte papier noch weit vor dem vor der
schrecklichen hochwasserkatastrophe in
rheinland pfalz und nordrhein westfalen
auf den weg gebracht hat um das bbk um
damit den katastrophen und
bevölkerungsschutz in deutschland zu
verbessern und zu stärken
es war horst seehofer der mit einigen
anderen regierungen in der europäischen
union eine koalition der willigen
geschmiedet hat um insbesondere
schiffbrüchige personen in deutschland
und den anderen ländern aufzunehmen also
sie gehen fehlen ihrem urteil
dass die letzte periode eine schlechte
periode in der innenpolitiker das
gegenteil war der fall in keiner
legislaturperiode seit bestehen der
bundesliga und haben die
sicherheitsbehörden in deutschland so
viel zusätzliches personal bekommen wie
in der letzten legislaturperiode das war
eine erfolgreiche vor eine gute regel
statt urteil wurde für die
sicherheitsbehörden und ich kann auch
mir einfach zu sagen dass ihre rhetorik
herr kollege hat man in keiner weise der
krisenhaften situation rechnung trägt
wäre uns
bei uns aus meiner sicht mehr seriosität
und auch mehr demut angemessen sehr
verehrte frau bundesministerin ich bin
der auffassung dass sie diese idee der
koalition der willigen naturhaus
richtigerweise übernommen haben und ich
weiß selber wie schwer das ist wenn man
auch die ratspräsidentschaft innehat
unter 27 eu-ländern hier einen
kompromiss zu bekommen trotzdem möchte
ich ihnen schon noch wärmstens ans herz
legen sich weiterhin nicht nur in
deutschland für eine gerechte verteilung
der glykämischen kriegsflüchtlinge
einzusetzen sondern auch auf
europäischer ebene gezeigt und ich bitte
sie auch dringend endlich die defizite
zu beseitigen die nach wie vor im
bereich der registrierung bestehen es
ist nach wie vor ein defizit das nicht
lückenlos alle ukrainische flüchtlinge
die nach deutschland kommen und
wohlgemerkt willkommen sind wird auch
registriert werden auch hier ist der
bund am zug sie lassen bis dato die
länder die kommunen und vor allem die
zehntausenden von ehrenamtlichen
jämmerlichen stich meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren und auch einem anderen
wichtigen gesellschaftspolitischen
bereich ist derzeit von der
bundesinnenministerium noch nicht allzu
viel zu hören und das ist der sport
bereich in den ersten 100 tagen sind sie
nur mit einer bemerkung aufgefallen
nämlich dass sie erklärt haben sie
würden nicht zu den olympischen spielen
nach peking reisen das war aus meiner
sicht mit verlaub eine fehlentscheidung
weil es unsere athletinnen athleten
verdient gehabt hätten dass sie auch
durch ein mitglied der bundesregierung
vor allem dürfte sportministerin
anerkennung finden für ihre live und das
war aus meiner sicht ein defizit darüber
hinaus wenn ich mir ansehe was im
haushaltsentwurf jetzt aktuell steht
dann ist ein zentrales vorhaben ihrer
bundesregierung nämlich die schaffung
einer unabhängigen instanz zur
mittelvergabe im spitzensport überhaupt
nicht abgedeckt durch irgendeinen titel
ansatz kein einziger euro steht in
diesem haushalt zu dieser unabhängigen
instanz und ein anderes wichtiges thema
unsere über 90.000 sportvereine die
jetzt wirklich gedacht und gelitten
haben in den zwei jahren der korona
pandemie brauchen mehr als nur warme
worte sie brauchen auch entsprechend
geld auch hier diesbezüglich steht kein
einziger euro im haushaltsentwurf der
sport etats was die verbesserung und den
neustart der arbeit unserer über 90.000
sportvereine anbelangt
wir unterstützen sie das sagen ganz
nachdrücklich auch bei der schaffung
eines
eines sportzentrums also vor allem eines
zentrums zum gegenstand hat das wir
sexualisierte gewalt im sport bekämpfen
dass wir athletinnen und athleten davor
schützen dass sie psychische oder
psychische psychischer oder physischer
gewalt ausgesetzt werden nur wenn ich
mir dann ansehen dass dazu gerade mal
ein haushaltsansatz von 300.000 euro
drin steht dann ist dies vollkommen
unzureichend untersagt nicht nur ich das
sagt auch der verein athleten in
deutschland gefallen also mein klares
beziehung sehr geehrte frau bundesinnen
und sportministerin hier wirklich
endlich die hausaufgaben zu machen der
sport ist eine der wichtigsten
gesellschaften in einer der wichtigsten
gesellschaftlichen bereiche in unserem
land und die bisherigen aussagen und vor
allem die bisherigen haushaltsansätze
traten dem in keiner weise rechnung
herzlichen dank der zuletzt viermal
stephan mayer der ja jetzt ein vier
jahre alter staatssekretär beim
bundesinnenminister war jetzt wie gesagt
neuer csu-generalsekretär und sprecher
für sport und ehrenamt und hat angemerkt
dass gerade für diesen bereich ehrenamt
geld vorbild
nächste gegnerin ist
jetzt vieles colat
von den bündnisgrünen
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine und die
damit verbundene millionenfache
vertreibung führen uns vor augen wenn
wir heute über den schwerpunkt des
haushalts des ministeriums für inneres
und heimat sprechen dann sprechen wir
vor allem über menschen und
das wird schon gesagt über einen neuen
stil an der spitze des hauses in der
flüchtlingspolitik zu gestalten und
nicht zu spalten meine damen und herren
minister acers kompass ist auf die
menschen ausgerichtet nicht auf zahlen
sie spricht von verantwortung begriffe
die sturm- oder lawinen kommen ihr in
zusammenhang mit geflüchteten nicht über
die lippen
meine damen und herren diese haltung ist
es die unsere koalition in der
flüchtlingsfrage auszeichnet und sie
unterscheidet sich dima diametral von
ihnen von der union meine damen und
herren
mit dieser haltung hat frau feser an
brüssel dazu beigetragen dass wenige
tage nach beginn des angriffs auf die
ukraine erstmals seit über 20 jahren die
eu richtlinie zum vorübergehenden schutz
von vertriebenen aktiviert wurde
und wie sie vom ministerium feser es
treffend formuliert hat wie renten
hätten menschenleben unabhängig vom
platz
nach jahrelangen streitigkeiten und
offene abschottung noch nie zeigte die
europäische union sich so geeint in der
flüchtlingspolitik die geschlossenheit
und solidarität mit der die eu staaten
sich jetzt bei der aufnahme geflüchtete
aus der ukraine präsentieren ist ein
wichtiges signal dies muss eine
blaupause für die künftige europäische
flüchtlingspolitik sein einer politik
die die menschen in den mittelpunkt
stellt
die antwort auf die größte flucht
bewegung in europa seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg muss sich aber auch maßgeblich
im einzelplan 06 der neuen ampel
koalition abbilden und vor allem frau
ministerin in den beratungen zum
ergänzungs haushalt sie haben es
angesprochen
wir werden den aktuellen
herausforderungen mit einer
integrationsoffensive begegnen wir
treten ein für gleiche rechte von anfang
an ohne wenn und aber und unabhängig vom
pass meine darboten
deshalb müssen jetzt auch die
gesetzlichen weichenstellung
gestellt werden ich hatte das in meiner
letzten rede schon gesagt und frau
ministerin die mittel für die
integrations und sprachkurse müssen wir
noch deutlich erhöhen
teilhabe findet auf vielen ebenen statt
das wurde heute auch schon gesagt ich
möchte hier insbesondere auch den
kommunen danken die in vorleistung
treten und all den freiwilligen die mit
großem einsatz die aufnahme der
geflüchteten ermöglichen insbesondere
auch dem ukrainischen migrant in den
organisationen die anerkennung dieses
engagement darf sich nicht auf worte
beschränken sondern muss sich noch
stärker im haushalt widerspiegeln und
frau ministerin ein
alleinstellungsmerkmal deutschlands ist
unser system der migrations erst
beratungsstellen auch hier reicht es
nicht die arbeit die arbeit der
wohlfahrtsverbände zu loben man muss sie
auch angemessen budgetär ausstatten
schließlich gilt es die vielen menschen
nicht zu vergessen die ins asylverfahren
gehen deshalb muss jetzt die
flächendeckende behörden unabhängige
asylverfahrens beratung kommen liebe
kollegin von der spd was
selbstverständlich sich auch im haushalt
abbilden muss
meine damen und herren
frau ministerin am 17 april wird es ein
gipfeltreffen geben der
ministerpräsidentin mit dem
bundeskanzler dort wird sich entscheiden
ob die menschen und ihre bedarfe im
mittelpunkt stehen oder ob diejenigen
sich durchsetzen die menschen in
geflüchtete erster und zweiter klasse
einteilen und die integration ausbremsen
wollen
zur teilhabe von anfang an gehört ist
geflüchtete aus der ukraine über die
leistungen des sgb zu versorgen sie
müssen krankenversichert und in den
arbeitsmarkt integriert werden teilhabe
gelingt nicht durch das abstellen in
sonder system der asylbewerberleistungen
liebe kolleginnen und das wird die
zentrale frage sein auch bei der
kostenteilung zwischen bund ländern und
kommunen auf dem kommenden flüchtlings
gipfel denn bleiben die menschen im
diskriminierenden sonder system trage
vor allem die kommunen die finanziellen
lasten diese frage erneut über
pauschalen regeln zu wollen das ist ein
griff in die mottenkiste der cdu und csu
sie hören aufmerksam zu herr kollege sie
wissen was ich hier gerade sage unsere
aufgabe ist es nun dass dieser haushalt
sowie der ergänzungsbau halt vom geist
unseres koalitionsvertrages getragen
werden wir wollen einen neuanfang in der
migrations und integrationspolitik
gestalten da einem modernen
einwanderungsland gerecht wird ich freue
mich auf die beratung frau ministerin
herzlichen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
nicola
[Applaus]
nächster redner ist der kollege johann
könig
ihren könig ist der sprecher für sport
sport gehört ja auch zum
bundesinnenministerium
und johann könig hat allerdings eine
sehr knappe resident sehr geehrte
kollegen und vor allem liebe sportler
der sport haushalt wurde in der 19
wahlperiode quasi verdoppelt nun ist
korrelationen noch nicht zwingend eine
kausalität aber in diesem speziellen
fall war entscheidend dass die ard zum
ersten mal im deutschen bundestag
vertreten war
die neue bundesregierung
hat den sport haushalt immerhin stabil
gehalten war jetzt rainer 310 millionen
euro ohne krone helfen wie als
ausgewiesene sportsfreunde von der afg
fordern aber ein aufwuchs von auf 360
millionen euro im haushaltsjahr 2022 und
konstruktiv wie wir sind haben wir die
entsprechenden haushaltsanträge schon
vorbereitet
langfristig fordern wir ein sport etat
von einer milliarde euro also in etwa
der größenordnung wie die kultur für die
hat der bund nämlich auch keine
originäre zuständigkeit
wir können uns das als sportnation und
das höre ich immer wieder als reiches
land ganz locker leisten
es gibt allerdings auf warnsignale aus
dem wichtigen haushaltstitel zentrale
maßnahmen auf dem gebiet des sportes
wurden 33 von 191 millionen euro im
jahre 2020 nicht verbraucht was war der
grund für diese 17 prozent
minderverbrauch corona die verschiebung
von olympia in tokio vielleicht
vielleicht gibt es aber nach jahrzehnten
der vernachlässigung des sports gar
keine sportler trainer und strukturen
mehr die den erfreulichen erhöhungen der
letzten vier jahre sinnvoll aufnehmen
können
wir von der alternative für deutschland
haben in der vergangenheit immer wieder
vorschläge gemacht um den
gesellschaftlichen stellenwert des
sports zu erhöhen wir haben uns mit
anträgen dafür eingesetzt dass es für
einen olympiasieg hunderttausend euro
gibt dass die trainer vergütung sicherer
und mit inflationsausgleich ausgestattet
wird und dass die fördergrenze für
sportgroßveranstaltungen aufgehoben wird
wir von der alternative für deutschland
werden auch in zukunft für den sport
genauso weitermachen
sport frei und vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
vielen dank herr kollege könig
ja er hatte nur zwei minuten hat aber
doch viel gesagt wie ich finde da sieht
man mal dass auch zwei minuten recht
lang sein können und es geht weiter mit
den sportpolitischen sprechern jetzt der
nächste redner kommt von den liberalen
für die fdp hier sehen wir schon philipp
habe ich er ist eben sportpolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte frau sportministerin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ein bereich der
in vergangenen jahren besonders unter
den pandemie bedingten einschränkungen
gelitten hat ist der sport der sport mit
all seinen facetten von der
gesundheitsprävention über den
klassischen breitensport die gesamte
fitness branche bis hin zum
leistungssport es darum die besondere
aufgabe und verantwortung den sport zu
schützen zu unterstützen und zu
entwickeln
beim schutz vor einschränkungen mit
debatten impulsen für die
gesellschaftliche bedeutung des sports
bis hin zum fundament erfolgreicher
sport politik und insbesondere für uns
als bund für besondere für erfolgreiche
spitzensport politik den finanzen der
spitzensport etat im einzelplan 6 und
hier sind wir auch beim breitensport
sind wir auch in anderen bereichen
kollege meyer zum beispiel beim bau
bereich von vor zwei tagen ist ein
solches fundament vorliegend der
vorliegende entwurf mit einem deutlichen
aufwuchs ist angesichts der schwierigen
haushaltslage ein starkes signal
es ist eine gute stärkung des
spitzensports und deutschland braucht
wettbewerbsfähigen sport spitzensport
genauso wie uns athleten beste training
zu wettkampfbedingungen benötigen der
entwurf beinhaltet die unterstützung
aller beteiligter akteure die ein
wertvoller beitrag leisten von der
verbandsförderung unmittelbare athleten
förderungen athleten vertretung durch
athleten deutschlands kampf gegen doping
förderung der sportstätten für
hochleistungssport die förderung
nationaler inhalts neue sprachkurs
veranstaltungen bis hin zum wichtigen
und notwendigen aufwuchs bei at&s
erfolgreicher spitzensport hat viele
baustellen baustellen hierbei bausteine
im zentrum stehen dabei aber natürlich
die wichtigsten aller akteure die
athletinnen und athleten die mit größter
disziplin an lebensträume arbeiten und
dabei unsere besten botschafterinnen und
botschafter in der welt aber auch für
unsere jugend sind danke aber auch an
der stelle an alle beteiligten die
großartigen trainerinnen und trainer
ehrenamtlichen in allen bereichen und
eltern die finanziellen und mit hohem
zeitaufwand große entbehrungen auf sich
nehmen großen dank aber auch an der
stelle unser partner die sporthilfe die
usb dbs bundeswehr oder bundespolizei
den karriere- und sport müssen immer
zusammengedacht werden und gute
sportpolitik ist immer teamaufgabe
zusammenfassend lässt sich sagen wir
stehen an der seite mit diesem haushalt
des spitzensports sind nicht nur die
koalition des aufbruchs sondern auch die
koalition des sportlichen erfolgs wir
haben eine gute grundlage ich freue mich
auf die weiteren beratungen sport frei
und vielen dank
viele länder haben
ich soll jetzt der kollege dr andré
berghegger cdu/csu partie
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte frau ministerin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren der haushalt des
innenministeriums mit seinen 19
nachgeordneten behörden umfasst rund 15
milliarden euro und über 80.000 stellen
ein breit gefächerter strauß an aufgaben
ich würde sagen ein schlüssel etat für
das zusammenleben in unserem land aber
dieser teil haushalt ist nicht
vollständig aussagekräftig denn er ist
der angekündigte ergänzungs haushalt
wird die auswirkungen der ukraine
situation des ukraine krieges auf unsere
finanzen abbilden so wie es der
finanzminister angekündigt hat deshalb
hier keine diskussion im detail das
machen wir gerne im haushaltsausschuss
und in der zweiten und dritten lesung
nur einige grundsätzliche anmerkungen
wichtig erst mal der hinweis bitte legen
sie uns den ergänzungs haushalt
rechtzeitig vor dass wir unsere
parlamentsrechte waren mit insbesondere
unsere oppositionsrechte ausreichend
wahrnehmen können
eine grundsätzliche anmerkungen seit der
regierungserklärung von bundeskanzlerin
vom 27.02 diskutieren wir die
einrichtung des sondervermögens
bundeswehr in höhe von 100 milliarden
euro
aber durch anmerkungen aus den
koalitionsfraktionen und durch die rede
des bundeskanzlers gestern in der
generaldebatte möchte ich wenige
klarstellende anmerkungen machen damit
das auch nicht in die falsche richtung
läuft gestern hat der bundeskanzler in
der debatte dass zwei prozent nato ziel
nicht mehr erwähnt wie in der
unionsfraktion gehen aber fest davon aus
dass wir ab diesem jahr dauerhaft
mindestens zwei prozent des bip in die
verteidigung investieren so wie es der
bundeskanzlerin
erklärung in der
42 gestern hat der bundeskanzler
außerdem gesagt und das fiel heute schon
in der debatte dass das wichtigste ziel
des sondervermögens sei dass die längst
überfälligen investitionen in
verteidigung und sicherheit nicht zu
lasten der drin der dringend notwendigen
notwendigen transformation zu einer
klimaneutralen wirtschaft gingen so weit
so gut aber als unions fraktion gehen
wir fest davon aus dass die 100
milliarden euro vollständig in die
ertüchtigung der streitkräfte das heißt
die verteidigung fließen und nicht mit
einem erweiterten sicherheitsbegriff in
andere themen untergebracht werden so
wichtig sie auch sein mögen
andere aufgaben müsste die koalition
dann in den jeweiligen etats finanzieren
und darstellen und ich sage es an dieser
stelle drittens so deutlich sehr geehrte
ministerin weil ich die diskussion auch
in diesem etat in die richtige richtung
lenken will denn neben der
richtigerweise deutlichen stärkung der
militärischen verteidigung wir haben es
heute mehrfach gehört muss die
korrespondierende zivile verteidigung
der zivilschutz der bevölkerung schutz
deutlich verstärkt werden das muss
jedoch aus dem regulären etat
erwirtschaftet werden und nicht aus dem
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
frau ministerin ich höre wohl dass sie
sagen es gab eine aufstockung aber
wenige wie soll ich formulieren
ergänzungen wenn sie sagen es gibt 100
neue stellen für das bbk dann ist das
schön und gut zur vollständigkeit hätte
dazu gehört dass damit dann die 100
knapp 100 befristeten stellen endlich
entfristet werden können und wenn sie
sagen dass das bbk mit konjunkturpaket
mitteln arbeiten konnte im letzten und
in diesem jahr dann müssen wir die
antwort geben was ist ab dem nächsten
jahr denn diese mittel sind nicht eine
nacht sind nicht eine nachhaltige
finanzierung das bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
bbk schützt und unterstützt die menschen
in besonderen notsituationen
ehrlicherweise führte es das haben wir
auch gehört in den letzten jahren ein
schatten dasein der spiegel titulierte
vor einigen jahren mal die vergessene
behörde das war ein auslöser und sehr
geehrte frau schäfer und sebastian
hartmann hat es auch so angesprochen ich
finde etwas die situation etwas zu
einfach zu sagen die union hatte 16
jahre lang das innenministerium und ist
für die situation des bbk
verantwortlich einige erklärungen dazu
die situation des bevölkerungsschutzes
verändert sich seit ungefähr 30 jahren
anfang der 90er jahre immer in absprache
mit der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
anfang der 90er jahre wurden die sie dem
in verantwortung des bundes zurück
gefahren mitte der 90er jahre fing man
an die luft schutz die luftschutzkeller
zurückzubauen ende der 90er jahre wurde
die vorgängerbehörde des bbk aufgelöst
und ein gewisser otto schily er war so
mal so zugeordnet ein gewisser otto
schily hat 2004 das bbk neu gegründet
und wir verlassen uns sehr auf 1,6
millionen ehrenamtliche in diesem
themenfeld und deswegen kann man nicht
so einfach sagen das war die union die
es für alle schlechte verantwortlich das
gegenteil ist der fall fast alle
fraktionen aus diesem parlament waren
über die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
oder über die regierungsverantwortung
hier in diesem thema befasst
wir sehen doch gerade in der jüngsten
zeit welche wichtigen funktionen das bbk
bei der bewältigung der korona pandemie
bei der hochwassersituation und aktuell
bei der bewältigung der folgen des
krieges in der ukraine hat sehr geehrte
frau ministerin sie waren glaube ich
nach meinem kenntnisstand mit dem
präsidenten des bbk in tegel und haben
sich dort das labor 5000 vom drk
betrieben ein projekt des bbk angeguckt
viele leute melden sich tagtäglich
zurzeit beim bbk und bitten um rat und
unterstützung und deswegen ist es doch
nur klug und richtig dass von der alten
bundesregierung beschlossene konzept zur
neuausrichtung des bbk aus dem letzten
jahr dass jetzt dringend umzusetzen mit
stellen und mitteln zu hinterlegen
von ministerin an dieser stelle
ehrlicherweise hätte ich mir gewünscht
dass das schon als antwort auf die
auswirkungen der krisen die wir haben
corona hochwasser dass das schon in
diesem regierungsentwurf auftaucht das
haben sie leider nicht geschafft aber
dann war nicht ihr wenn ich jetzt waren
dann und deswegen wird sich da müssen
wir deutlich nachlegen spätestens mit
dem ergänzungs haushalt ein zweites
grundlegendes thema die bewilligten
mittel müssen natürlich auch abfließen
und nicht als reste übertragen werden
die stellen wie wir vor sehen die müssen
natürlich zügig ist besetzt werden ich
hatte vorhin gesagt dieser etat alleine
weist über 80.000 stellen aus einen ganz
großen teil davon im sicherheitsbereich
egal ob man sich die absoluten oder die
relativen zahlen anguckt der unbesetzten
stellen das ist eine ganze ganze menge
das sieht liegt das liegt sicherlich zum
teil daran dass stellen frei gehalten
werden für auszubildende die jetzt
gerade vorbereitet werden und dann die
stellen übernehmen aber nicht nur wir
haben aus gutem grund die
sicherheitsüberprüfung eingefügt
eingeführt und vielen
sicherheitsrelevanten bereichen aber wir
müssen noch aufpassen dass die stellen
die diese überprüfung durchführen dass
die abläufe gestrafft werden dass wir
ausreichend personal dorthin bekommen
dass die wartezeit nicht so lange sind
denn es kann nicht sein dass uns gute
qualifizierte leute in der zwischenzeit
über monate abwandern zu anderen
arbeitgebern geben gehen wir brauchen
jede gute frau und jedem guten man hier
für diese tätigkeit
aber jetzt kehre ich zum anfang meiner
ausführung oder anmerkungen zurück frau
ministerin
alles andere ist zurzeit nebensächlich
widmen sie sich bitte mit ganzer kraft
den auswirkungen des krieges gegen die
ukraine alles andere kann im moment
dahinter zurückstehen sorgen sie bitte
für eine gute für eine schnelle für eine
professionelle aufnahme der flüchtlinge
aus der ukraine das kann nicht dauerhaft
durch das ehrenamt geleistet werden
sorgen sie für eine lückenlose
lückenlose registrierung für eine
angemessene verteilung und unterbringung
der menschen in unserem ganzen land
berücksichtigen berücksichtigen sie
dabei auch die diejenigen die über
private wege um kontakte hierhin
gekommen sind das ist doch ganz wichtig
und zu guter letzt auch das wurde
mehrfach erwähnt lassen sie die kommunen
nicht im stich sorgen sie für eine
angemessene kostenverteilung zwischen
bund ländern und gemeinden schieben sie
das nicht auf eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die
irgendwann anfang anfang april kommen
wird lassen sie das nicht einfach
geschehen übernehmen sie eine aktive
rolle das erwartet glaube ich die
bevölkerung und wir auch vielen dank des
bundes betrieben
der bundestag berät über den einzelplan
06 inneres und heimat 19 nachgeordnete
behörden hat nancy faeser und
80.000 stellen das ist mal eine echte
hausnummer kann man nicht anders sagen
der nächste redner ist jetzt
fraktionslos matthias helfrich er wollte
eigentlich wie der achter verziehen
werden hat sich dann aber im vorfeld als
freundliches gesicht des nationalismus
nationalsozialismus selber bezeichnet
würde da hoffentlich aufgehen und der
linkspartei im parlamentarischen
kontrollgremium
vertreter verwehren sie wollen hier die
großen demokraten sein und das gremium
was den verfassungsschutz und andere
geheimdienste kontrollieren soll hat
keine vertreter der oppositionsparteien
auf der demokratisch linken auf der
demokratischen rechten seite das zeigt
sie sind extremisten der mitte und sie
führen die geheimdienste gegen die
oppositionsparteien diese ins felde sie
wollen 675 millionen euro
integrationskurse stecken als
kommunalpolitiker aus dortmund weiß ich
dass die erfolge der integrationskurse
nach der integrationskurs verordnung gar
nicht nach gehalten werden wir wissen
nicht einmal wer das sprach level b 1
erfolgreich abschließen aber das haben
sie ja auch erkannt und diese chance
genutzt um ihren müll wieder etwas geld
zu zu pumpen die regierung butter 13
millionen euro in die zitat abhebung
einer sozialpädagogischen begleitung von
teilnehmenden in integrationskursen
konkret wollen sie also
sozialpädagogische massenzuwanderung
gewinner dafür bezahlen dass sie den
müßiggänger mit migrationshintergund
auch das händchen dabei halten wenn
diese deutsch auf grundschulniveau
erlernen und das soll ihre fachkräfte
zuwanderung sein das geld wäre besser in
die rückführung all jener zuwanderer
investiert die sich lediglich in unsere
kriminalstatistik investiert in
integriert haben und in clans
organisiert sind sie haben groß
angekündigt
feser dass sie eine umfassende
rückführung offensive gegen klares und
kriminelle ausländer starten wollen doch
wie meine anfrage an die bundesregierung
ergab können sie nicht beziffern wie
hoch die abschiebung von clan
mitgliedern und kriminellen ausländern
sind mein name ist ampel ich weiß von
nichts ihre massen zuwanderungspolitik
ist ein must programm für klaren
strukturen in meinem heimatland nrw das
politische lager bild des landen des lka
zeigt dies ganz klar die das
libanesische klaren establishment hat
jetzt schon angst vor den syrer und
irakischen klaren strukturen und wenn
sie es wirklich mit der sicherheit in
unserem lande ernst machen dann starten
sie ihre rückführung offensive ich werde
sie gerne dabei unterstützen
meine damen und herren und sie sehen
nach wie vor das kleine fenster bei uns
wir warten immer noch auf die
pressekonferenz von kohl als kanzler
scholz nach dem simulator gefühl aber
das wird sicherlich in wenigen minuten
und der fall sein der bundestag
debattiert also nach wie vor für den
einzelplan und heimat
der letzte redner hat sieben einzuplanen
ist lars castellucci
für die spd-fraktion aus dem ausschuss
für inneres und heimat und es kann sein
dass jahren tatsächlich oder
berechnungen müssen
sondern auch würdelos sprach und ging
das ist ja kein parlamentarisches
verhalten
aber kommen wir zu unserem
tagesordnungspunkt vor vier jahren stand
an diesem pult bei der debatte um den
haushalt im inneren der damalige
bundesminister horst seehofer und er hat
einen masterplan migration angekündigt
in seiner rede ein masterplan migration
der zuerst mal zu einem riesenstreit in
seiner eigenen fraktion in seiner
eigenen partei geführt hatte danach in
der gesamten regierung der unterschied
ist dass wir heute eine regierung haben
die vom ersten tag handelt und zwar mit
geschlossenheit und entschlossenheit in
dieser rede hat der damalige
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer
ebenso angekündigt dass er nun reisen
werde und hat sich ausgerechnet als ziel
ausgesucht nach österreich zum damaligen
bundeskanzler kurz zu fahren der uns
glücklicherweise mittlerweile auch
abhanden gekommen ist und von dort dann
weiter nach ungarn also ausgerechnet
denjenigen den rücken zu stärken die
jahrelang für die blockade einer
europäischen gemeinsamen politik im
bereich von migration und asyl
verantwortlich waren der unterschied ist
dass wir heute eine innenministerin
haben die aus dem stand zu diesem
gemeinsamen europäischen vorgehen
beigetragen hatten einstimmigen
beschluss herbeigeführt hat so dass wir
heute unkompliziert und gemeinsam die
geflüchteten aufnehmen können das ist
ein unterschied das ist eine
glanzleistung von ihnen frau
innenministerin
als letzten redner in dieser debatte
steht es mir zu ein paar dinge noch
einmal gerade zu rücken die in der
debatte so nicht stehen bleiben können
das erste ist der schutz der menschen
die zu uns kommen wird die kollegen von
der union sie schildern es so
als ob die menschen die frauen die
kinder an den bahnhöfen in diesem land
von menschenhändlern in empfang genommen
würden und von triebtätern abgeholt die
sie in ihre privaten wohnung locken
wollen und sie wissen ganz genau dass
ist ein zerrbild das sie hier entwerfen
die wahrheit ist die wahrheit ist dass
wir eine fülle von ehrenamtlichen und
hauptamtlichen kräften alles tun dass
die menschen hier gut in empfang
genommen werden können und sie sollten
aufhören solche zerrbilder zu entwerfen
ein generalverdacht hier in diesem land
zu versuche zu erzeugt
ich kann ihnen versichern diese
regierung tut alles mit der
bundespolizei mit informationskampagnen
mithilfe telefon dass die menschen hier
schutz erhalten den sie suchen und dass
sie die sicherheit haben die sie
brauchen
ein zweiter punkt ist die registrierung
die sie hier immer wieder ansprechen ja
die gefahr die sie da wittern hinter dem
busch die kennen sie selber ganz gut ich
weiß was da bei ihnen los ist denn es
war ihr eigener innenminister damals
noch de maizière der vor dem bundestag
getreten ist und gesagt hat alle sind
registriert und hinterher sich
herausgestellt dass war ja gar nicht so
heute haben wir eine völlig veränderte
situation die menschen reisen visumsfrei
1 sie haben 90 tage aufenthaltsrecht und
sie werden am ende da wo sie ankommen
registriert das ist kein defizit in der
umsetzung kollege meyer sondern das
recht und gesetz rechtsstaat was wir
hier zur anwendung bringen und das hat
seine gute ordnung
mehr noch als das die bundespolizei
kontrolliert gegenzug und jeden bus und
kommt so sehen zahlen die uns allen
mittlerweile vorliegen in höhe von etwa
230.000 menschen die mittlerweile im
land sind zu denen werden dann noch
diejenigen dazu kommen die privat
eingereist sind oder an den grenzen
direkt abgeholt werden das ist also ein
funktionierender rechtsstaat den wir
auch dank unserer sicherheitsbehörden
hier leisten können die sie auch in
diesem haushalt nochmals stärken mit
einem aufwuchs der bundespolizei von
fast 1000 stellen ich glaube dass wir
mit diesem haushalt unserer
verantwortung sehr deutlich gerecht
werden ich danke ihnen für die
aufmerksamkeit uns bitte sie tun sie
alles damit wir diese bewährungsprobe
gemeinsam gerecht werden können vielen
dank in sotschi
weitere wortmeldungen liegen mir nicht
vor